Google Cloud NEXT '21
Google Cl
Google Cloud NEXT '21 Google
Cloud NEXT '21
Google Cloud NEXT '21
>>APARNA SINHA: Hi.
I'm Aparna Sinha.
Welcome to Day 2 of Google Cloud
Next!
I'll be co-hosting today,
alongside Urs HÃ lzle, and we've
got a really great lineup of new
technology and demos from Google
Cloud.
But before we get started, I
want to thank you all for taking
time out of your busy week to be
here with us.
Yesterday was an incredible
first day at Next!
Thomas and Sundar made some
amazing announcements.
This week, we're releasing over
100 new products, services and
programs for you.
We're kicking off Day 2 now with
This keynote, "a cloud built for
developers," after this, we'll
jump right into a live developer
Q&A, where you can ask us
anything.
And then tomorrow is community
day, and that will be totally
Dede indicated to you for
learning, discussions,
networking and all kinds of fun.
All right!
Let's get things started by
welcoming Urs!
Hi, Urs!
>> Hi, Aparna, hi, everyone!
I hope you're as excited as I am
to get started today, and since
this is a developer keynote,
we'll kick it off with our first
demo right away from Google
Research, and our colleagues who
have been working on some
amazing voice technology.
>> Welcome to Next '21!
To start, I'd like to thank you.
Wherever you are in the world.
For coming and sharing.
Your time with us today.
>>URS HÃ-LZLE: Now, before you
get too impressed by my language
skills, I did not actually speak
these words.
What you just heard is a custom
text-to-speech model that has
trained on my voice and can
generate synthetic speech in
different languages.
And our teams have already
started using it to improve our
voice technology for all users.
>>APARNA SINHA: That's right.
Google's Project Euphonia is
already using Custom Voice to
help people with atypical speech
to communicate and be better
understood.
Technology like this creates a
more inclusive world.
To find out more about this,
check out the Project Euphonia
Web site.
Custom Voice is available today
for select Cloud customers.
We're very mindful of the
potential misuses of this
technology and we're taking
great care to prevent them by
reviewing each unique use case.
URS HOLZLE: Now, look around
you.
Every day you see innovation
that was brought to life by
developers like you with
persistence and talent.
Google has a long tradition of
supporting developers in open
source.
For years, developers have been
Using technologies like
Kubernetes, Firebase,
TensorFlow, Go, Angular and gRPC
And many others.
When we built Google Cloud, we
built it for
developers, and we're inspired
By all the things we've created
with it.
Our job so to make it easier for
For you to do what you love.
So we focus on making you as
productive as possible with the
least amount of effort.
So in everything we design, we
take all the feedback you're
Sharing with us and build a
Cloud platform that just works.
Whether that's by natively
embedding key security or
sustainability features into
The platform itself, or by
featuring
partner solutions right within
our console, we're focused on
one goal, giving you the best
developer experience of any
Cloud provider.
>>APARNA SINHA: Google Cloud has
had tremendous traction with
Digital Native customers since
Our very early days.
How have you seen customer and
partner adoption evolve since
then?
URS HOLZLE: Well, many of our
biggest customers are cloud
Natives, but we see tremendous
adoption by a broad segment of
enterprise customers in
traditional industries as well,
like entertainment and financial
services.
For example, Major League
Baseball, which is North
America's oldest and
most-attended professional
sports league, is using Google
Cloud to modernize fan
engagement and increase
operational efficiency.
Equifax, founded in 1899, and
one of the world's largest
Consumer credit reporting
agencies, is transforming itself
from a credit bureau to a
next-generation data, analytics
and technology company built on
Google Cloud.
>>APARNA SINHA: We've seen a
huge shift, essentially every
company is becoming a tech
company to increase
competitiveness and establish
leadership in their industries.
Developer talent and cloud
services are at the heart of
this shift.
Whether you call it "digital
transformation," or something
else, companies of all sizes are
finding that Google Cloud is
optimized to help make your
data, your applications and your
talent more useful and relevant
to your business.
>> URS HOLZLE: Exactly.
As Thomas mentioned yesterday,
everyone needs to be thinking
through how they'll
fundamentally shift into a
technology company to serve
their customers in the most
meaningful ways ten years from
now.
You, as developers, are key to
Making this happen.
So, organizations ask
themselves, do we have the most
cutting edge technology to
become a leader in our industry?
You, the developers, are
well-equipped to answer this.
And we are super focused on
making you and your company
successful.
And there's two areas we
focus on to support your growth.
First, of course, making it
easier for developers to get
their job done.
Second, investing in the
developer community, so that
everyone can learn and grow from
each other.
Let's talk about how Google
Cloud is making it easier for
developers to get their job
done.
From our transformational
infrastructure stack to our deep
innovations in data, security
and AI, every feature we release
starts with simplifying
developer experiences.
Take our open cloud
Experience, for example.
We recently expanded our compute
stack to include Tau VMs, which
deliver 42 percent better price
performance over other
comparable options in the
market.
Thanks to our Zero Trust
approach to security, Google
Cloud was ranked leader in IaaS
Platform Native Security by
Forrester.
Well ahead of the competition.
And of course we're focusing
also on managed services that
make it
easy for you to deploy, scale
and manage Kubernetes anywhere.
Google Cloud has the most
complete and most secure
container experience for
developers.
The 2021 Gartner's Solution
Scorecard for Google Kubernetes
Engine gave GKE an overall score
of 92.
Again, well ahead of the
competition.
And with GKE and Anthos, you can
run these containers anywhere.
On-premise, other clouds and on
the edge.
You know, anywhere.
So it's fair so say that in the
years since Google
invented Kubernetes, containers
have completely revolutionized
IT operations.
Recently, European filmmakers
from Honeypot.io created a
documentary on the history of
Kubernetes, and it will be out
in January 2022.
You're the very first audience
to have a look at the trailer
now!
So let's roll that.
>> Do I look at you?
Look at camera?
>> 2013, it was clear that Cloud
was a thing, but most folks were
focused on infrastructure Cloud.
The dirty secret for a long time
is like, you know, people who
were either building their own
data centers or using COLOs,
there's a huge resource waste.
>> And so at that point,
automation tools are all the
rave.
People are now trying to
abstract away the servers.
>> Google was looking for ways
to apply its internal
infrastructure expertise to the
Cloud.
>> As we started looking at
technologies like Docker, we
were, like, impressed by the
strength of what they had
accomplished in solving a very
specific problem.
>> This is going to happen with
us or without us.
>> Google had to make a bold
move in the cloud space to be
the long-term winner.
>> Every big start-up I felt
like had a container
orchestration project, and half
of them were announced at
DockerCon 2014.
>> Open source is most
successful when it's played as a
positive sum game.
>>APARNA SINHA: This is such a
great community!
>> URS HOLZLE: Yeah.
Absolutely.
I recognize a lot of the faces,
and I can't wait to see the
film.
Now let's get back to how we're
making it easier for you to
build the leading technology
companies of tomorrow.
Kubernetes deployments can
involve a fair bit of manual
configuration of clusters,
nodes, load balancers, YAML
files, et cetera.
But not on Google Cloud.
We offer you the most automated
and secure Kubernetes experience
available.
With GKE Autopilot, Google
provisions and manages the
cluster's entire underlying
infrastructure, including the
control plane, node pools and
Worker nodes, and that lets you
focus on the higher-level
services and applications that
you're building.
Nobody else offers anything like
this!
Beyond managing node upgrades,
GKE Autopilot automatically
configures security features
like Shield GKE Nodes, Secure
Boot, and Workload Identity.
And it also implements
security best practices by
blocking less safe features such
as external IP and legacy
authorization.
You don't get a toy Kubernetes
cluster with GKE Autopilot.
You get a sophisticated cluster
that uses the best practices
brought to you by the team who
Brought you Kubernetes itself.
You're always up to date and get
the same results as the experts,
without having to be an expert
yourself.
>>APARNA SINHA: The pandemic put
developers in the driver's seat,
and they drove GKE usage to
all-time highs.
At the same time, we saw
explosive growth in the use of
Google Cloud's serverless
offerings, especially Cloud Run
and Cloud Functions.
It's mainly enterprise
developers who have driven this
growth.
Cloud Run excels at developer
Experience.
It's earned the highest
customer satisfaction rating
among developers as measured by
User Research International.
Cloud Run combines the best of
both worlds, bringing you
Serverless, and containers.
There's no cluster to set up or
configure, so developers are
able to scale seamlessly and
securely.
Under the hood, Cloud Run scales
container instances in isolated
sand boxes.
Any access outside a sand box is
mediated by network controls,
Or identity and access
management, or both.
And this isn't just for new
apps.
Cloud Run supports traditional
workloads like Java Spring Boot,
and ASP.NET.
We also recently introduced
committed use discounts to lower
the cost at scale and "always on
CPU" enabling asynchronous and
Background processes to be used
on Cloud Run.
So you have all the benefits of
serverless without the
restrictions.
The theme here is easier, more
secure development.
Especially with remote work.
>> URS HOLZLE: You're absolutely
right.
We've been focusing on remote
development for some time now,
But the pandemic has certainly
accelerated the shift.
What's more essential to remote
development than to be able to
use the full power of GCP right
from a laptop with zero local
setup?
Cloud Shell Editor is a context
aware, remote development
environment that lets you
develop and manage applications
securely from any browser.
It supports languages like Go,
Java, Node.js, Python and C#.
It comes with an integrated
debugger source control, API
explorer, and if you want to
test locally on your laptop, it
Also comes with local emulators
for Kubernetes and serverless
API's.
>>APARNA SINHA: Thanks, Urs!
Next, let me introduce Abby
Carey, who will show us how
Google Cloud makes it easy for
you to securely build modern
Applications, again, right from
your laptop.
Hi, Abby!
>> Thanks, Aparna!
We developers have had a hard
time writing, extending,
deploying and operating
applications, but it doesn't
have to be difficult.
Let's start with Cloud Shell
Editor.
It comes with current versions
of your favorite Dev tools, like
docker, minikube, skaffold and
more.
There's nothing to download or
install locally.
Tutorials are built into Cloud
Shell Editor, which makes it
easy to come up to speed on
complex topics like GKE.
>>APARNA SINHA: No more
switching between tabs, docs,
your terminal and your code.
This integrated experience is
highly differentiated from other
clouds.
You can even author your own
tutorials, allowing your
organization to share best
practices and onboard new hires
faster.
>> Another popular feature is
Kubernetes YAML authoring
assistance.
Let's say I want to add YAML for
a service to this project.
I can press control + space,
find the Kubernetes service
Snippet.
Now I can tab through and fill
everything in.
I also get autocompletes, and if
I happen to make a formatting
mistake, I'm notified there's an
issue in real-time.
>>APARNA SINHA: Many of you
prefer to work locally in IDE.
The same YAML authoring
assistance is also available for
VSCode and IntelliJ via the
Cloud Code plug-in.
Cloud Code has built in support
for both Cloud Run and
Kubernetes.
>> In fact, if you're using
Cloud Run or Functions, you
don't need to know Docker.
You can build and deploy your
app with just one command
because Cloud Build is
integrated under the hood.
This is an application with no
dockerfile.
With the newgcloud run deploy
command, all I have to do is
Provide a name for my service,
and then let it know where my
source code lives, which is this
current directory, and we're
deploying.
So nice.
>>APARNA SINHA: Nice!
And thanks to this ease of use,
98 percent of users deploy an
application to Cloud Run on
their first try in less than
five minutes.
>> I just showed source code
deploys to Cloud Run.
But there are more ways Google
Cloud has made deployment easier
and more secure.
First, I can scan my built
container images to check for
vulnerabilities.
I've already run an on-demand
scan on one of my images using
gcloud artifacts docker images
scan.
Now I can copy the ID of the
scan, and view my image's
vulnerabilities with the list
vulnerabilities command.
And then once that's finished, a
severity level is assigned to
each vulnerability to help you
prioritize.
>>APARNA SINHA: That's super
important!
It's really helpful in
addressing security concerns
earlier in the software
development life cycle.
But what if your build pipeline
is compromised?
>> For that, I can enable Binary
Authorization on my deployed
Cloud Run services.
This way only trusted container
images are deployed to
production.
>>APARNA SINHA: Binary
Authorization is truly unique in
the industry.
It enables you to put proactive
security measures in place to
reduce software supply chain
attack risk by blocking
deployments that violate policy.
And speaking of deploying, we're
making it seamless for you to do
CI/CD securely.
You can take advantage of
serverless build environments
within your own private network
with Cloud Build private pools.
>> And for advanced CD, we have
Google Cloud Deploy, which
allows you to create custom
delivery pipelines for your
specific use case and needs.
>> That is so cool.
>>APARNA SINHA: A real
application connects to many
supporting cloud services.
Can you show us an example of
how we've made integrations
easier?
>> Sure.
When creating a Cloud
Function, it's easy to integrate
with Secret Manager.
First, create a secret that
stores an API key, which I
already did.
Now, either mount it as a volume
or expose it as an environment
variable.
I'll mount it.
And then I'll name my mount
path.
This will always point to the
latest version of the secret.
Now I can securely reference
this API key from my source
code.
This abstraction enables
portability and a better local
development experience.
Cloud Run also integrates with
Secret manager to make it easier
to do the right thing and not
put sensitive data in source.
>> Love that so much.
Okay.
So now you've
written your app, deployed your
app and connected your app to
other Google Cloud resources,
what's next?
>> Operating your app in
production!
With Cloud Ops, you get one
Integrated view for your alerts,
events, metrics and logs.
No more jumping around multiple
tools as you try to understand
what went wrong.
>> That was so awesome, Abby!
Thanks for sharing this with us.
>> Thanks, Aparna!
>>APARNA SINHA: In each of these
instances, we've done the
integration work for you.
Because the more work we put
into this, the less work you
have to do.
This principle applies to
security as well.
We've put a lot of energy into
building security natively into
everything we do, so you can
innovate with assurance.
Both GKE and Cloud Run benefit
from the security fixes we
implement before vulnerabilities
are exposed.
Just look at the famous
vulnerability uncovered in how
Kubernetes was handling proxy
requests.
We found it, coordinated and
communicated the disclosure,
We fixed it for the entire
Kubernetes community, and we
patched all our products before
any customers were impacted.
Now recent cyber threats have
shifted the focus to software
supply chain.
>> URS HOLZLE: That's right.
Malicious actors are trying to
compromise the software supply
chain from bad code
submission to bypassing the
CI/CD pipeline all together.
To help solve this problem, we
have proposed an industry-wide
standard called SLSA.
It's a security framework that
provides common criteria for
increasing levels of software
security through automation and
cryptographic signing at each
stage of the software supply
chain.
And that makes it possible, but
not necessarily easy, and so
making it easy for developers to
ensure security is super
important.
That's why we're focused on
Building security right into the
developer tool chain,
anticipating and preventing
issues ahead of time, not when
you are most at risk.
For example, Cloud Build, our
service that lets you build,
test and deploy across multiple
environments such as VMs,
serverless, Kubernetes, or
Firebase, now offers SLSA Level
1 compliance by default.
Because Cloud Build gives you
verifiable build
provenance.
This provenance lets you trace a
binary to the source code to
prevent tampering and prove that
the code you're running is the
code you think you're running.
Cloud Build is the first and
Only CI/CD service to
offer such a capability.
But we go beyond that.
As you've seen, Build Integrity
automatically generates digital
signatures which can then be
validated before deployment by
manual authorization.
That's another Google Cloud
first.
And so without you needing to do
anything, we prevent anyone in
your organization from deploying
code that has not been built by
your legitimate build system.
Now, Ensuring security
post-deployment is equally
critical.
On GCP, you can enable
continuous scanning and use our
Service Mesh to embrace a
zero-trust security model and
automatically and declaratively
secure your services and their
communication.
You can manage authentication,
authorization and encryption
between services, with little to
no changes to the applications
themselves.
Let me say that again.
With little to no changes to the
applications themselves.
So that means that these
security improvements help
secure not just new code, but
existing binaries as well, so
you can use them for any
application you're migrating to
the Cloud.
Both Anthos Service Mesh and now
Cloud Build Hybrid are available
across Google Cloud and on your
premise environment and work
with VPC Service Controls and
VPC Peering to automate
developer security for your
enterprise.
No other cloud provider protects
your software supply chain to
this level.
Because we started working on
software supply chain security
long before it was in the
headlines, and by choosing GCP,
You benefit from this
leading-edge focus on security.
>>APARNA SINHA: Whether we're
building foundational open
source technologies like
Kubernetes and Istio or turning
them in to fully managed
services like GKE and Anthos
Service Mesh, our goal is to
reduce complexity for our users.
By helping create industry
standards, we can provide safer
and simpler services for
You, the developer.
This is exactly our approach to
securing the software supply
chain.
We co-founded the Open Source
Security Foundation with other
technology leaders to create
security standards for open
source.
And we're starting to bring
products to mark like Open
Source Insights, which provides
a complete transitive dependency
Graph for many open source
packages.
Now let's turn to Urs to hear
why Google Cloud is best
positioned to support you in
becoming a technology leader in
your industry using data as a
core asset.
>> URS HOLZLE: Thanks.
Yeah.
So far, we've been talking about
developing and managing code.
But data is at the heart of many
enterprises.
We also have the leading data
cloud products in the industry,
designed for optimal performance
And reliability for applications
of all sizes while scaling to
immense capacity.
Let's start with databases.
When it comes to databases,
every cloud gives you choices.
They offer SQL databases, which
Are great, but unfortunately
don't scale.
And, of course,
noSQL databases which do scale,
But unfortunately are not SQL.
Only Google Cloud gives you a
third choice with Spanner.
Spanner is SQL.
And, in fact, it just got a
Postgres interface, but it
scales horizontally, and it can
literally handle a billion
requests her second.
Nobody else has a scaled SQL
system.
On the data warehouse side, we
have the leading cloud data
warehouse with BigQuery.
Hundreds of customers are using
BigQuery at petabyte scale
today.
Petabyte each.
And you can run BigQuery Omni on
AWS or Azure.
Open source systems for data
lake processing like Flink,
Spark and Beam, run natively on
Google Cloud in a simpler and
more cost-effective way than in
other environments.
In fact, you can realize 57
percent lower TCO compared to
on-premise data lakes for data
science projects.
On top of that savings, our data
cloud also includes the world's
first and only autoscaling and
serverless Spark service.
And finally, Google has deep
partnerships with leading
data-driven companies, including
Databricks, Confluent, MongoDB,
RedisLabs, and many others.
Together, we help customers
access an open platform that
powers analytics at scale yet is
easy to use.
>>APARNA SINHA: Our partner
community is central to the
health of our Cloud business.
We are especially excited about
the innovation from our Data
Cloud partnerships.
Together, we have optimized our
Infrastructure for performance
and efficiency to give our
partners that extra edge when
they run on Google Cloud.
One of our leading partners in
MongoDB, we have their CEO, Dev
Ittycheria here with us today.
Welcome, Dev.
>> Hi, everyone.
Happy to be here.
>>APARNA SINHA: Dev, one of the
trends we are seeing from
enterprise customers is that
they're now competing for
leadership positions in their
industries by becoming
technology companies.
How did you say Google Cloud and
MongoDB working together can
help these customers achieve
that transition?
Well, the companies who are in
the leadership positions in
their industries are those who
have built their competitive
advantage using software and
data to transform their
business.
The keyword here is build.
You can't buy a competitive
advantage.
You have to build it.
This means you need to enable
your developers to innovate as
quickly as possible, whether
it's building new software to
seize new opportunities or to
respond to new threats.
MongoDB and Google Cloud both
deeply understand this, which
.
Developers choose manMongoDB an
Google Cloud because we give
them the tools they need to be
as productive as possible,
including having our services
available in the Google Cloud
console for easy discovery and
deployment.
With Google's analytic and AI
tools.
This enables our customers to
innovate quickly and emerge as
leaders in their industries.
As a result, we're seeing
explosive growth in our
customers embracing the true
value of our partnership.
>> That's incredible.
So what's the biggest challenge
that you're helping them solve?
>> When you talk to development
teams, their biggest challenge
is managing data.
Serving relevant data at the
right time to the right audience
is critical to building any
application.
Unfortunately, relational
databases are not designed for
the way developers think or
code.
Nor are they designed for scale,
fault tolerance, or resilience.
Consequently, development teams
find it hard to use fast using
relational databases.
MongoDB is designed to address
this problem.
We make it very easy for
developers to work with data and
we're able to address the most
demanding requirements for
performance, scale and full
tolerance.
The partnership enables
developers around the world to
easily build modern software
applications, to address their
needs today and tomorrow.
>>APARNA SINHA: Terrific!
Thanks so much for being here
with us today.
>> Thank you for having me.
>> URS HOLZLE: Yes.
Thanks, Dev, for joining us.
There are lots of ways
developers can improve their
productivity.
Automating tasks that are
repetitive, mastering the
command line, using the best
tools that make your life
easier, or reuse others' code,
just to name a few.
Another great way to accelerate
your productivity is with
building blocks, templates, and
fully managed services in areas
like machine learning.
With Google Cloud, you don't
have to be an expert to build
smart applications.
With new services like Vertex
AI, you can build, deploy and
scale more effective AI models
quickly.
This lets you deliver the
insights to your organization
that will help them create more
personalized customer
experiences, run more efficient
processes, and take a leadership
position in your industry.
>>ALISON WAGONFELD: .
>>APARNA SINHA: So with that,
let's go to our next live demo.
how these breakthroughs in AI
are advancing Cloud adoption and
redefining the world of document
processing.
Hi, Anu!
>> Hi, Aparna!
We all know how to work with
data when it's in a structured
format like in a
database,json,csv, or just
variables in my code, right?
But what about unstructured
data?
Many of the world's business
processes start, include or end
with a document, but these
documents can be difficult to
process.
Think about the ways you could
enhance your application if you
Could just unlock that data.
could unlock that data.
This is where Google Cloud
document AI comes in.
DocAI is a platform that has
solutions and tooling for
automating your work flows,
backed by machine learning.
We've bundled together some of
Google's flagship AI technology,
such as computer vision, OCR,
Natural Language Understanding,
and even Google's expertise in
building knowledge graphs to
provide you with a simple, yet
powerful way to build
applications that better
understand unstructured data.
Let's see a demo of docAI in
action.
So here we have a receipt.
I was buying some office
supplies, since we are
unfortunately not back in the
office yet.
What I'm going to do is
I'm going to upload this in to
the docAI Platform in the Cloud
Console, where we have this
Built-in preview mechanisms so
you can test out your documents.
So this going to an end point,
which has a specialized model we
have specifically trained on a
variety of expenses.
Google maintains and improves
the models for you.
>>APARNA SINHA: Wait a minute!
I hope this is not with my data.
>> Absolutely not.
We never use your data to train
our models.
Your data is only used to serve
your request.
So let's take a look at the data
extracted.
>>APARNA SINHA: I've seen this
before.
Next you're going to tell me
That you're going to automate my
expenses.
>> I knew you would say that,
But have you ever seen it like
this?
Take a look at this field that
I'm highlighting, the supplier
address.
This address isn't present
anywhere in the document.
>> APARNA SINHA: Wow, where did
that come from?
>> This is only possible with
Google's Document AI.
The secret sauce here is that
the
knowledge graph, which not only
gets back the original text, but
It's going to enrich your
response, akin to what you'd see
in a search, but as part of your
API response.
>>APARNA SINHA: That's great!
>> And it's not just this.
We have several specialized
models for many more document
types of much higher complexity.
Take a look at this pay slip.
So I ran this earlier, and we're
looking at the preview output
again.
You can see that we have some
keys, some fields.
You can see enrichment on the
employer name and the address.
Once your data is in a
schematized format, meaning that
we know for every document of a
certain doc type, there are
common important pieces of
information.
So what we did is we pre defined
a set of keys.
So what we do is with your
extracted data, we merge the
data to these pre-defined keys,
so it's much easier to work with
than raw OCR.
So once it's in a schematized
format, it's easier to pass down
to a service or maybe you're
using something for analytics
like BigQuery or Looker.
>>APARNA SINHA: That makes
sense, but what about
ensuring accuracy, and, more
importantly, do we have
multi-language support?
>> We know with important
documents such as these you
can't afford any missteps when
it comes to accuracy.
That's why Document AI also
provides a human in the loop
configuration to trigger on
Confidence scores so either for
specific keys, or on the entire
document itself.
And for translation, we support
over 100-plus languages such as
Spanish, Japanese and Arabic.
No other solution on the market
supports such a wide array of
languages.
>>APARNA SINHA: Human in the
loop, translation and knowledge
graph capabilities that can be
applied to a wide variety of
documents.
This seems super useful!
Of course, the next big question
is, can it be applied to big,
bulky, complex documents like
business contracts?
>> Let's take a look.
So here I read a contract
earlier this morning.
You can see that there are
typical things you'd find in any
contract.
There's some document names,
the parties involved, some
dates, and like with every
"easy-to-read" contract, being
sarcastic here, there is an
expiration term.
So this expiration date actually
isn't present anywhere on the
document, and it's actually not
easy to figure out.
It's not in an easily parsable
format.
Shocker!
Google's contract processor is
able to figure out this date
value by understanding signals
found across the entire
document.
>>APARNA SINHA: Anu, before you
go, can you tell our awesome
developers how to get started
with docAI?
>> Absolutely.
I know we covered a lot at
breakneck speed, so please do
check out the breakout sessions
on docAI to dive deeper.
You can also check out the
Documentation for code labs and
quick starts.
We have client libraries in all
your favorite languages, such as
Python, Node.js, my personal
favorite, Java.
But it's an API, so you can use
this with whatever
Platform or framework you're
already using.
We are thrilled and look forward
to seeing how you use Google
DocAI to power your
applications.
>>APARNA SINHA: That was
amazing!
Can I have a high five?
Yeah.
Thank you, Anu!
I loved every part of it!
>> Thank you for having me.
>> URS HOLZLE: Another area
Google has invested in deeply
and that is becoming
increasingly important to more
Companies is sustainability.
Many cloud providers have a
vision for a sustainable future,
and many aim to match their
electricity consumption with 100
percent renewable energy by 2025
or 2030.
We accomplished 100 percent
renewable energy in 2017, so
we're the only hyperscale Cloud
to do this today.
And all of that with data
Centers that are twice as
efficient as the average data
center.
>>APARNA SINHA: This past week,
Sundar talked about Google's
goal to enable over a billion
users to live and work more
sustainably by next year.
To reach goals like this and
those outlined in climate
pledges made by more
organizations every day, we rely
on developers like you to do
something about it.
But we also know that it's
difficult.
>> URS HOLZLE: That's right.
One of the
biggest challenges companies
face is they lack the tools to
account for environmental costs.
To help developers address this
for their organizations, we
built sustainability tools
Directly into Google Cloud.
With Google Cloud carbon
footprint, you have access to
energy related emissions data
you need for external carbon
disclosures in just one click.
Now, you won't need this
calculator if you just want to
report the net carbon footprint
of your workload on GCP.
Because on GCP, it's always
zero.
We also have our region picker,
where you can choose the data
center
region with the lowest gross
carbon cost.
Of course, your net impact is
zero, no matter what region you
pick, but this tool helps you go
one step further to become
carbon free, not just carbon
neutral.
Now, that's actually a tool that
I can't wait to deprecate in
2030, or so, because Google
Cloud has committed to be 100
percent carbon-free by 2030,
every hour of every day.
Now, we also realize
there is still a lot to learn
when it comes to building
sustainably.
To help, we just released a
master class called "sustainable
IT-Decoded" with some of the
world's top experts.
Check it out for guidance on how
we can all build more
Sustai
Sustainably.
While we're proud to run the
cleanest cloud in the industry,
we're even more inspired by the
work our customers are doing
with Google Cloud to solve
climate change challenges unique
to their business.
And today, we bring you a
preview of Google Earth Engine
and its integration with Google
Cloud.
With over 700 data sets and more
than 50 petabytes of data today,
Earth Engine gives scientists
and developers access to the
world's largest catalog of
Satellite imagery, and to tools
for driving sustainable impact.
>>APARNA SINHA: Now let's look
at this a bit more closely with
an example of how Google Earth
Engine and Google Cloud enable
customers to assess risks
arising from climate change.
But instead of me telling you
about it, we've invited Joel
Conkling to show you.
>> Thanks, Aparna!
The world is constantly
changing, and that creates
Opportunities and risks.
Helping uncover critical
insights about the changing
world is why we're integrating
earth engine into Google Cloud.
That integration is now in
private preview.
Today, I'm demo a work flow that
combines Vertex AI, Earth
Engine, BigQuery and Maps to
show how Google Cloud makes it
incredibly easy for you to
innovate and deliver insights,
and do it quickly!
Here's the scenario.
You work at an insurance
Company and you need to analyze
your company portfolio's
exposure to flood risk.
You think that the new buildings
may be a strong contributor to
that risk, and you want to test
your hypothesis.
To do that, we first need to
understand where the built
environment is expanding.
In other words, we need to
categorize the surface of the
planet.
That could be hard, but
Vertex AI offers the tooling to
develop a best-in-class ML
model, and Earth Engine provides
constantly updated data.
Let's fast forward a bit.
We finished training our model.
And now Earth Engine is sending
satellite imagery to be
categorized, so your
understanding of the world can
update in near real time.
Here's the earth engine script
showing the results of that
model.
This area in red is where the
model
estimates the locations of
buildings.
That's your current built
environment.
To find the change over time, we
need a few more lines of code.
These lines of code give us a
built environment to 2016.
Can and here we calculate the
difference between 2016 and
today.
When there's a change, it shows
up in purple on the map.
This is where there are new
buildings.
So next, we're going to sample
and export the data so we can do
additional analysis in BigQuery.
This script clusters those data
points here, and then outputs
polygons that show the area with
the biggest changes in the built
environment.
So at this point you have a few
options.
You can identify this data with
flood locations you identify
around the world, also with
Earth Engine.
Maybe you want to enhance your
model with weather data and
physical train data.
That's in Earth Engine, too.
You can also include data on
your company's insurance
portfolio to get additional
insight into critical risks.
We'll wrap up this demo by
visualizing your results at a
new feature available on Google
Maps platform, the open source
data library, with a BigQuery
connector, so we now have a
clear picture of where the built
environment is changing and
where to focus next for our work
on flood risks.
In summary, no wrangling data,
no need to manage
infrastructure, just actionable
insights incredibly quickly.
We can't wait to see what you'll
do with Earth Engine's new
innovation with Google Cloud,
and with that I'll pass it back
to Aparna.
>>APARNA SINHA: Thank you, Joel.
It's incredible to see how our
customers can use our
sustainable technologies to
address climate change now.
I'm inspired by all the things
we've talked about today.
Thinking about how you're going
to lead your companies into the
future, that's exciting!
No pressure, but it's really up
to you!
We've invested millions in the
developer community over the
last five years, and we'll
continue to invest in the coming
years.
Urs, as proof of that, I
understand you have some
additional news to share today.
>> URS HOLZLE: Absolutely!
I'm really excited to announce
Today our new developer
community program called Google
Cloud Innovators.
I want to welcome and introduce
our first group of leaders who
are driving meaningful impact in
the industry and their
communities.
Take a look.
>> This is so exciting!
>> URS HOLZLE: Yeah.
Through this
program, we'll give developers
deeper access to early
technology previews and front
line engineers.
We'll recognize the expertise of
our community influencers by
promoting their contributions
And we will work closely with
them to solve the toughest
problems.
We're excited to come together
with this group of innovators!
Join us at
cloud.Google.com/innovators.
>>APARNA SINHA: So cool!
I've been waiting for this all
this time!
Community is extremely important
For companies to create that
much needed human connection
with developers.
We hope this gives you a window
into the motivation you all give
Google to build Cloud products
and services that developers
love.
>> URS HOLZLE: And we look
forward to partnering with you
to become the greatest tech
companies in your industries.
>>APARNA SINHA: Remember to join
us at the next live developer
Q&A session, and tomorrow at
Community Day!
Enjoy the rest of the show!
>> Thanks everyone!
>> Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining us today for
the developer live Q&A.
A reminder that this Q&A is
live.
If you want to join the
conversation, reach out on
twitter with the #Google Cloud
next.
We've reached out asking for
your questions on social media
and you all have been
responding.
We'll be answering your
questions during the next 20
minutes.
And first of all, let's welcome
Prianca, who's here to answer
your questions with me here
today.
Hi!
>> Thanks, Aja.
That keynote was absolutely
amazing.
Yeah.
So let's get into the goodness
that Urs and Aparna shared.
A highlight for me was really
that upcoming documentary on
Kubernetes.
So cool.
I also enjoyed the Google Cloud
innovator community
announcement, securing software
supply chain, and building
sustainably.
What caught your eye?
>> A lot of the stuff you just
mentioned.
Definitely our innovations and
sustainability.
The ability to see your carbon
footprint of your cloud
workloads is really, really
cool.
When I heard about it in
yesterday's keynote, I
immediately went and looked at
all my personal projects to see
the carbon cost of what I've
been doing, and I love having
that kind of data to use in
decision making, like help me
make the right decisions.
But I'm mostly really excited
about the cloud innovators
program.
I've really missed interacting
with our Google Cloud Dev
community.
I want to hear and see all the
amazing things the community's
been up to.
And the innovators program
should let us do that, and we're
working on some super special
innovators only events in 2022
that I can't wait to tell the
community about.
>> Wow.
Yeah.
That all sounds really amazing.
I'm so excited about that secure
supply chain announcement, SLSA.
And how the combination of Cloud
Build and binary authorization
actually helps kick start your
journey to secure your software
artifacts by fully automating
that build process.
>> Yeah, that's just so
interesting.
So cool.
So let's get to our first
question.
We've got the questions coming
in.
Just for the folks at home, back
stage crew is looking for your
tweets as well, so keep them
coming in.
We'll be bringing them in live.
So our first question is from
Asher, and it is who would be
good candidates for the
participation in the private
preview of earEarth Engine?
Yeah.
So anybody who is, like, doing
work on sustainable things,
right?
So with the sustainability lens,
if you're thinking about
financial services, the customer
packaged goods and their impact
on the environment and how all
of that can be combined
together.
So yeah, anything that you're
doing with the sustainability
lens.
Obviously it's in private
preview, so you have to qualify
and stuff, but if you have that
angle of sustainability, you're
probably a right fit for it.
>> Awesome.
Thank you for that.
Second question came in from
Priyanka's twitter, and I saw
this this morning as I was
coming in to do this Q&A.
And this is any examples, do we
have any examples of end-to-end
spark Plains for ML.
They'd love to see them.
Specifically, they're interested
in learning how spark can be
leveraged to work on big data on
Google Cloud.
>> Yeah.
So thank you for this question.
I see it came from Prana.
I saw my twitter this morning.
So really, what it's all about
is the serverless Spark ML
framework is about you not
having to create your backend
infrastructure to Spark.
So that's all taken care of for
you so you can just run your
workloads, which is, in this
case, you're trying to run a
machine learning Spark job, you
can just get started by not
worrying about the
infrastructure.
So that's one part.
The other piece of it is the
workbench, which is the Jupiter
notebook, but hosted, but it
also gives you the opportunity
to connect with data or the
Spark ML jobs that you might
have built, and run all of that.
So as a data scientist, I can
just use my workbench, and that
becomes my home to kind of get
the data, massage it, connect
with data prog, spaSpark ML job
and then get all those
predictions right in that one
spot.
>> Awesome.
Thanks, that was a really
comprehensive answer.
So now we have a question from
Christopher and it's what are
the benefits of the innovators
program.
Do you mind if I take this one?
>> Yeah, please.
So the big benefit is going to
be access to innovators only
events.
We're going to be doing some
AMA's we're planning right now,
road map meetings, potentially,
and there's also a background
that you can download and use in
your Google Meet meetings.
Another question came in from
twitter.
Awesome.
So let me read this one.
Massive focus on the security,
massive focus on security focus
on the developer cloud.
Isn't this a topic that matters
more for the managers of
developers than for developsors?
And I'll take this one, too, if
that's cool with you.
>> Yeah.
>> So I'm a manager, and yeah,
that's a really good question.
Security is vital to all aspects
of software development and
security needs to be everyone's
job.
Yeah, managers need to care a
lot about it but we need to make
the tools so that the developers
can do the right thing
automatically, and that everyone
is participating in making our
cloud more secure.
And we talked about some of
those things.
We talked about our tooling that
can help you make sure that you
put your secrets in secure
locations as opposed to putting
them in code.
We talked about the SLSA.
We talked about lots of other
parts, and all of this requires
secure software supply chain,
but security does need to be
everyone's job.
Managers can help by teaching
their developers and enforcing
it, but everyone needs to take
the steps to make things more
secure.
So, yes.
Good point.
But everyone's involved.
Okay.
This is a great one from
Priyanka's linked in.
Is it possible to connect to the
public IP from a Cloud SQL to --
I've been asked this one before.
Also, is this cross-project
set-up, Cloud Run service and
cloud-run SQLs are on -- can you
do a project with your database
and your running of service
somewhere else?
Priyanka?
>> You actually can.
So in this scenario, you have
Cloud SQL instance in one
project, and you have your --
you have your compute, or
whatever is calling that Cloud
SQL instance in another project,
and you could totally make them
work by using what is called as
private service access.
What it does is it connects the
two together, even with a
private IP.
So you don't even have to expose
a public IP for your cloud SQL
instance, which is, again, comes
back to the security point you
were making earlier.
Everybody has to think about
security.
So you're not exposing with
public IP, you're just using the
private IP of your Cloud SQL
instance and connecting it to
the washing machine or wherever
you're running your compute to
call your search from.
So it's possible private service
access is the service you're
looking for to kind of connect
the two together.
It
>> Awesome.
Thank you so much, Priyanka.
Cool.
A question from Andy.
Ooh, this is one of my
favorites.
So there's a lot of ways to run
an application with Google
Cloud.
It's a huge platform.
How do I know what I should
choose?
Where do I run my stuff?
Should I run it on GKE?
Compute Engine?
Cloud Run?
So many good choices.
>> Yeah.
This is a question we get a lot,
right?
And it really just depends on
your situation and the
situations can be a lot, the
type of team, the size of team,
and the number of -- the number
of developers you have, and the
languages that you might be
using.
So there are lots of different
scenarios in which you can
decide.
So I'll give an example of a
few.
So, for example, compute engine.
Like, if you're migrating and
you just want to get from
on-premise infrastructure into
Cloud, and you just want the
speed, you just want to get
there, I would choose Compute
Engine to just migrate as is and
then modernize later, if needed.
Sometimes you don't need to
modernize, if you have licensing
requirements and stuff like t
t
that.
So that's compute engine.
If you want to work with
containers, need a little bit
more abstraction -- less
abstraction, you can work with
containers with GKE, and that
gives you a lot more control
over the number you have and the
processing you're using.
But if you might be just wanting
to run containers, but don't
want to manage the underlying
infrastructure, the nodes and
stuff like that, and the
regions, just use Cloud Run
because it's serverless, but it
allows you to use your contain
er images and just deploy them.
Cloud functions is kind of like
everywhere.
So you're trying to do -- handle
one function, or a piece of -- a
piece of a feature of code that
you just deploy in that function
as a function, as a code sort of
service, but it kind of applies
everywhere.
So I wouldn't say -- so Cloud
function is not like an or, it's
more of an and.
Like it works with any of those,
it's just more of an extension
and enhancement of your services
with serverless.
So I hope that helped clarify a
little bit of that, but there's
a lot that goes in that
decision.
>> Yeah, and I really liked how
you called out that cloud
functions is not an or, it's an
and.
Cloud functions is just
fantastic.
It time pieces together.
That's one of the things I love
about it.
And I'm just going to point out
for folks that we have sessions
on all of these in the
breakouts, so if you want to go
learn more about these, go look
in our breakouts and you can
find out more about the
different offerings that Google
Cloud has.
What languages dDo Cloud-run an
cloud function support?
Let's see if I can do this from
memory.
GCF.
These are -- we've got node GS,
python, Go, java, dot-net, Ruby
and PHP.
I got them all.
Awesome.
Cloud Run supports any language
or any library or any binaries
that you can put in the
container, but if you want to
use the source code deploys
feature that Abby showed
earlier, that is supported on
node, python, go, java and do
dot-net and specific versions of
those languages are supported so
please do go to the Web site and
make sure that the version that
you need is the one we support.
>> Great memory, by the way.
>> Oh, yeah, I'm getting really
good at naming all those
languages.
So from Selena, when should I
use GKE Auto Pilot versus Cloud
Run?
>> I'll let you take that one.
>> You want to let me take this
one?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> So this pretty much boils
down to do you want Kubernetes
or not.
If you want Kubernetes, if you
want the enhanced flexibility
that Kubernetes has, if you want
to have all those knobs and
dials that you can turn to
really fine-tune everything for
your networking needs or your
particular load profile, use GKE
auto pilot.
If you have a container and you
want to run it on GCP, and
that's your goal, Cloud Run is
great.
Cloud Run is fantastic at that.
And as we pointed out, you don't
even need a container if you use
Cloud Run source deploys for
those raunings I jlanguages I j
mentioned.
>> More questions.
Ooh, this one is for you.
This is from Caleb.
What file formats are supported
with the Docu stuff?
>> You can do images and PDF's.
It's really about the
unstructured image data.
So PDF's and images.
>> Awesome.
Okay.
Let's see what else we got.
Ooh.
This one's from Mark.
Another one for you, Priyanka.
Ooh, it's another security
question.
So the you tell us more about
binary authorization?
We covered it very briefly in
the keynote, but it's something
I've been hearing a lot about
and I'd love to know a little
more about it.
>> Yeah.
So again it kind of boils down
to like the whole like security
narrative that you mentioned
that everybody's kind of
responsible for for the security
of the entire platform.
So in this case, with binary
office really deploy time
security.
So you're deploying and making
sure that your images or
container images, if you're
using GKE or Cloud Run works
with binary, so when you're at
your deployment stage, you can
provide signature authorizations
on your images.
So if -- and the verification
and the authorities for those.
So if they are authorized,
binary auth will apply the
authorizations and once the
image is authorized, only then
you can deploy it.
>> Awesome.
So I just got the signal that
we're running out of time.
So this is going to
unfortunately be the last
ques
question.
And this question comes from
Wesley.
Can I use the build integrity
features with my on-prem
software?
>> Hmmm.
Okay.
Yeah.
So you kind of can.
So with Cloud Build, it's really
any container image, which is
built on cloud build.
You can use both -- you can use
it in both on-prem or on Google
Cloud.
You just have to use the binary
attestation Cloud Build, and
it's on the GitHub page, so you
can check that out.
But if you're building it with
-- in Cloud Build, you can
deploy it on prem, or in Google
Cloud.
>> Thanks, Priyanka.
Well, that was a lot of fun, and
it was great to hear all the
questions from the audience.
Y'all had some great ones.
And I want to say just a huge
thank you to Priyanka for
joining us and answering so many
of those questions.
Be sure to join us back over on
G.co/cloud next, as the
spotlight will be kicking off
shortly, and they have some
amazing things that they're
going to show off.
Thanks for joining us, everyone!
>> Hi, everyone.
I hope you enjoyed the Dev
keynote.
I'm Jeff Reed, VP of Product for
Application Modernization
Platform at Google Cloud.
Thank you so much for being with
us here today.
In most of my conversations with
customers, I found they're
accelerating their technologied
option through the use of
cloud-based services to build
and deliver new capabilities
like curbside pickup in retail,
remote diagnostics in
manufacturing, and completely
new experiences to better
support their end customers.
Today I'm going to share some
exciting announcements that will
further empower you to digitally
transform your organization.
We recognize that each company
has unique Cloud needs, so we at
Google Cloud are focused on
three areas to support you in
whatever stage you are in your
Cloud evolution.
First, we set out to make your
migration or modernization path
easy.
With Google Cloud, you can
easily evolve your existing
applications or build new Cloud
native apps.
Second, our open platform
extends Google Cloud's services
in engineering practices to
hybrid and multi-cloud
environments for consistent
service delivery.
And third, our planet scaled
distributed infrastructure is
transformative and delivers the
highest level performance and
availability in a secure,
sustainable way.
One of our primary goals is to
make it easy for you to deploy
and scale and manage Kubernetes
anywhere.
In the years since Google
invented Kubernetes, containers
have completely revolutionized
IT operations.
Given our history, it is not
surprising that Google
Kubernetes Engine, GKE, is the
leading solution in the market,
and even Gartner agrees.
In the recent Gartner Solution
score card, GKE scored 92 out of
100, making it the absolute
strongest strategic option among
public Cloud Kubernetes
services.
Until now, Kubernetes has
involved a fair amount of manual
configuration.
You have to manage your own
Clusters, nodes, YAML files,
it's a lot.
With our introduction of GKE
autopilot, a new mode of
operation in GKE, we're making
it much easier for you to use
Kubernetes.
Google provisions and manages
the entire clusters underlying
infrastructure, including the
control plane, node pools,
worker nodes, letting you and
your developers focus on your
software while GKE autopilot
manages all aspects of the
infrastructure.
In the midst of the pandemic, we
saw a large number of our
customers adopting serverless
technologies, and that's no
surprise since serverless
technologies enables companies
to rapidly develop and deploy
any application in a fully
automated environment.
With services like Cloud
Functions, Eventarc and
Workflows, you can easily set up
event-driven, serverless work
flows that connect in to Google
Cloud, third party SAS services
or your own applications.
Serverless is also about running
complex workloads at scale while
still preserving a delightful
developer experience.
In fact, serverless with Cloud
Run is about delivering a true
developer platform with the
flexibility to run any language,
any library, any binary.
You can bring traditional
workloads such as Java Spring
Boot, ASP.net, and more to
Serverless Compute now.
Whether it's GKE AutoPilot,
Cloud Run or Cloud functions,
our goal is to make it easy for
you to build and scale apps how
you want and where you want.
Our second focused area is
delivering an open
infrastructure Cloud.
It relies on open-sourced based
technology, like Kubernetes, SGO
and K-native, delivering the
portability you expect.
It also offers you the choice
and flexibility to build the
manager apps across multiple
clouds.
To realize these benefits,
Anthos operates as a
cloud-backed control plane that
provides consistent development
and management at scale across
both Edge, on-premise, and
multi-cloud environments.
It then enables you to build and
manage global fleets and
establish operational
consistency at scale.
Let's hear from my colleague,
Rae Wang, who interviewed
Jahidul Khandaker and Suraj Rao,
the CIO and global head of
advanced analytics at Western
Digital on their multi-cloud
journey.
>> Welcome.
And thank you for sharing your
insights with our audience.
We have been working together
since 2019 on Western Digital's
Cloud transformation.
What initially prompted you to
focus on modernizing
applications and standardizing
software delivery across your
organization?
>> Thank you, Rae.
We are happy to be here.
As a result of various merger
and acquisitions, WGC became an
integration of three
corporations, HESD, WDC and
Sandisk.
To support very diverse
infrastructure and IT
environments across the three
entities, switching to a Cloud
strategy became an imperative
for driving to a
standardization.
>> Now, Jahidul mentioned about
the cloud strategy.
In 2018, we saw tremendous
growth in IOT applications from
our global factories that
required low latency and
high-speed, on-premise
solutions.
However, now we were faced with
this daunting task of keeping
our on-premise and the Cloud
solutions synced up.
This led to exploding solutions
that provide a uniform
management plane across our
hybrid environment.
After trying multiple solutions
for over two years, we chose
Anthos.
Anthos gives us the diagnostic
solution that works across GCP
and on-premise environments
while keeping the doors open for
a multi-cloud future.
>> That is great to hear.
Go, Anthos!
So what does hybrid Cloud
strategy mean to Western
Digital?
>> Sure, Rae.
Western Digital is making a
pivotal strategy shift to Anthos
for our big data platform.
We are migrating more than 25
business-critical applications
seamlessly to this hybrid
environment with Anthos.
This move has several
advantages, a richer user
experience, greater security and
enhanced flexibility to manage
factory applications.
Some of these critical
applications include image
analysis on millions of images a
week for factory disposition.
Machine learning will close for
real-time factory decisions, and
many, many others.
>> Thank you.
That's a great strategy and some
amazing use cases.
Now looking forward, what are
your upcoming digital
transformation goals in the next
three to five years for Western
Digital?
>> Rae, the future at Western
Digital is very exciting.
We want to deliver excellence
everywhere.
Ultimately, we see Cloud
technology as an enabler of our
key business priorities, reduced
time to deliver services,
rationalize our application
footprints, and meet customer
demand for IOT and edge
applications.
>> Thank you, Jahidul and Siraj.
I look forward to amazing work
from this great partnership.
>> Thanks, Jahidul, Siraj and
Rae.
Since we announced Anthos back
in 2019, we are thrilled with
the reception it has received in
the market.
In fact, as of Q2 2021, Anthos'
compute undermanagement grew
more than 500 percent year over
year.
And today, we are extending
Anthos towards even more
workloads and more environments
and in more locations.
We are announcing Anthos for VMs
to support development teams
that want to standardize in
Kubernetes, but have existing
workloads running on virtual
machines that cannot be easily
containerized.
Once you shift or attach VMs
directly to the Anthos
environment, you can leverage
declarative configuration and
policy management with Anthos
config management, and
end-to-end application
visibility and security with
Anthos service mesh.
We're also introducing one of my
favorites, Anthos Multicloud
API, which enables you to
provision and manage GKE
clusters running on AWS and
Azure infrastructure through a
centralized Google backed
control play.
Generally available today.
The Anthos Multicloud API
ensures your team has a
consistent experience to create,
manage and update GKE clusters,
regardless of which major public
cloud you're using.
Thank you for joining us on the
path to revolutionizing Cloud
computing.
Now I'm going to hand it over to
Sachin Gupta, VP GM for
Infrastructure and long-time
friend, to talk about how we're
extending these innovations to
your dedicated environments.
>> Thanks, Jeff.
>> Great to see you, friend.
>> It's great to be here in
person and it's great to see you
all.
Our goal in Google Cloud is to
meet you where you are in your
digital transformation.
We understand some of your
workloads cannot move to the
public Cloud entirely due to
various factors, such as high
amounts of local data
processing, low latency
requirements, or strict data
security and privacy
requirements.
But as you've heard yesterday
from Thomas, we're working to
help you solve some of these
constraints.
With the announcement of Google
Distributed Cloud, we're
extending our infrastructure to
the edge and to your own data
centers.
This announcement allows you to
further digitize your business
applications by ensuring they
have the speed, intelligence and
processing power in managed
heterogenous environments, and
we're approaching this from a
differentiated standpoint
relative to other cloud
providers.
First, we bring Google's AI and
Analytics Solutions closer to
where the data is being
generated and consumed to
harness real-time insights.
Second, Google Distributed Cloud
is enabled by Anthos.
It helps you to build and run
applications on GKE clusters and
virtual machines anywhere with a
Cloud-backed control plane for
consistent management at scale.
And third, our Planet Scale
Infrastructure delivers the
highest level of performance and
availability on the most secure
and sustainable platform.
Google Distributed Cloud is a
fully managed, integrated
hardware and software solution,
meaning you don't have to worry
about the underlying
infrastructure and can focus on
your applications and business
initiatives.
We aim to simplify operations,
leveraging Google's expertise
and track record in areas like
scale deployment, fleet
management and site reliability
engineering.
This allows you to focus on your
business priorities and leave
the complexities to us.
Google Distributed Cloud is
designed for running sensitive
workloads that meet sovereignty
requirements and offers private
5G LTE solutions for enterprise
customers.
There are four deployment
scenarios depending on the
customer's need:  The Google
network edge, the operator edge,
the customer edge and customer
data centers.
R
The first use case I'll talk
through is at Google's network
edge, which is designed for
single and multi-tenant use
cases, leveraging over 140
Google network edge locations
worldwide.
Next is the operator edge.
This is owned by communication
service providers for both
single and multi-tenant Cloud
use cases.
As I mentioned before, you'll
benefit from 5G LTE services
provided by our operator
partners.
It can accommodate emerging
services and applications with
stringent latency and
reliability requirements.
For example, online games and
game streaming depend on low
latency to preserve the end user
experience.
Then we have the enterprise
customer edge.
These are customer-owned edge
locations such as retail stores,
factory floors or branch
offices, which require localized
compute and processing directly
in these edge locations.
Next, the customer data centers
are customer-owned facilities or
co-lo facilities and are set up
for single and multi-tenant
hybrid scenarios.
It's also ideal for life cycle
management of virtual network
functions for communication
service providers that reside on
premises, such as Cloud native
buildout of private 5G networks.
Google Distributed Cloud also
includes a hosted mode to run
sensitive workloads.
Hosted mode helps you meet
sovereignty needs by addressing
data residency with strict
security and privacy
requirements, all while
providing you with a way to
modernize on-premise
deployments.
Customers can manage this
directly or host through a
designated and trusted partner.
The good news is that hosted
mode does not require
connectivity to Google Cloud at
any time to manage
infrastructure, and uses a local
control plane for operations.
Upgrades in patches are offered
by Google, and verified by the
trusted partner.
To learn more about how
customers are leveraging
Google's Distributed Cloud, I'd
like to welcome Rasesh Patel,
chief product and platform
officer, AT&T.
Rasesh, welcome to Next.
>> Thanks, Sachin, it's so good
to be here with you today.
>> Rasesh, why don't we dig
right in and have you tell us
about how you're looking to
leverage Google's distributed
cloud for your edge and
computing needs.
>> You bet.
I'd start with saying AT&T and
Google have similar goals when
it comes to edge compute.
We both want our business
customers to build and run
modern applications close to
their end users.
By moving compute workloads
closer to the user, we can
reduce latency to levels that
will allow for a whole new range
of mobile experiences that
weren't possible before.
Sometimes this compute will be
on the network edge.
Sometimes it will be at the
customer premise.
But regardless of where the
compute workloads occur, this is
not something AT&T's going to do
alone.
>> That is tremendous.
It is really fascinating how
communications has been able to
influence business revolution,
and it looks like you're poised
to do it all over again.
So what kind of new business
outcomes do you think we can
bring together with 5G and edge?
>> You're absolutely right,
Sachin.
Our goal is to create net new
business services and customer
experiences.
Let me give you some industry
examples.
In retail, services including
streamlining automated inventory
management, predicting and
managing queues, even enabling
cashierless checkout options
will come to life.
In healthcare, we see secure,
multi-gig connectivity for all
devices within a hospital, the
advent of remote patient
diagnostics and care, and rapid
data transfer between field base
emergency medical services like
an ambulance, and hospitals.
And in the entertainment
industry, we're enhancing
in-venue experiences for
concerts and sporting events
with solutions ranging from
immersive AR and VR experiences,
smart parking, ticketless entry
to contactless food and souvenir
payment.
>> Last question.
What are your goals for AT&T and
Google partnership in the next
three to five years?
>> Well, our work together
brings market transformative
capabilities to businesses
across many industries.
5G and fiber-based edge
connectivity and compute with
Google's powerful ecosystem that
includes maps, voice
recognition, AI, Android and
many other capabilities, enables
the development of these next
gen experiences in an
accelerated time to market.
And we're looking forward to a
lot of expansion.
We're bringing our network-based
solution with Google Cloud to
over 15 major markets in the
next several years.
We have plans to roll out the
services in major metro markets,
including Chicago, Atlanta,
Dallas, Miami, San Francisco and
many more.
So stay tuned.
>> Thank you for joining us,
Rasesh, and we look forward to
continued success and delivering
joint value to our mutual
customers.
Thank you again, Rasesh.
>> Thanks for having me.
>> Everything you just heard
about Google Distributed Cloud
is made possible by Google's
planet scale infrastructure.
To ensure you're successful, our
infrastructure delivers several
key differentiated benefits,
including a global network
construct, performant and
customizable compute services,
and reliable and secure storage.
First, at the core of this
infrastructure is the world's
largest and lowest latency
network with 27 regions, 82
zones and 146 points of presence
located in more than 200
countries all interconnected
with 16 subsea cables.
It enables companies like major
League Baseball, Wayfair and
1-800-flowers to quickly migrate
existing enterprise workloads to
Google Cloud and will continue
to invest in our global network
and global reach.
This year alone, we have already
added four new cloud regions,
Warsaw, Delhi, Melbourne, and
Toronto.
Moreover, with simpler
networking solutions such as
Network Connectivity Center, you
can easily connect ST WANs,
VPN's and interconnect with a
centralized management model and
monitor the network with network
intelligence center.
And with private service
connect, you can connect at the
service layer without
configuring the underlying
network.
Second is our performant and
customizable compute platform.
Compute engine allows your
applications to achieve higher
reliability, security and scale
without any of the operational
toil.
We recently announced a new VM
family, Tau VMs, which is
optimized for scale-out, digital
native workloads.
Tau VMs offer 42 percent higher
price performance than
alternatives from any other
leading cloud provider.
As of today, I'm also excited to
announce the preview release of
new Spot VMs.
With Spot VMs, you can use
excess compute capacity at
deeply discounted rates, and our
new Spot VMs offer better
savings and more predictable
pricing than alternatives from
any other leading Cloud.
Third, our business business
continuity and storage options.
Our strategy is about tendering
your storage to your workload so
we can meet your price and
performance needs.
To advance our storage as the
best option for global
enterprises, we recently
introduced three important new
services.
The first is backup for GKE,
which is an easy, Cloud-native
way for customers to protect
their configuration and data
running in their containers.
The second is filestore
enterprise, a Cloud Native
managed NFS storage solution
that offers 99.99 percent
availability SLA, and is ideal
for running enterprise
applications such as SAP and
GCP.
And the third is additional
robust business continuity
features for cloud storage that
extends the unique, single-name
space model we have with dual
region buckets.
You now get more choice in where
your data is stored with custom
dual-region buckets, and the
option of a new market-leading,
15-minute RPO SLA.
We're passionate about helping
customers continually evolve
their approach to modernization,
and bring more of their
applications and data to the
Cloud.
Google Cloud is planet scale,
available wherever you need it,
while also providing cutting
edge innovations in performance
and security.
Our goal is to make your journey
to Cloud easy by offering
transformative capabilities to
help you innovate faster and
save money through an open
approach that enables
flexibility and choice.
Next, I'm going to turn it over
to the demo team to bring the
magic of Google Cloud to life.
So stick around, and after the
demo, we'll be taking your
questions in a live Q&A.
See you then!
>> Hey.
Welcome, everyone.
I'm Richard.
>> Hi.
I'm Vitia.
>> We're really glad you joined
us here today.
We're going to have a lot of fun
talking tech, and I wish you
could be here with us
personally, but we're live, at
least, and it means we can kind
of say anything, I guess I could
say Google should bring back
Google Reader, and I'm still
working here, so that's awesome.
If you have some other hot takes
and want to share some feedback,
put it in the chat.
We can see that live.
So keep it coming.
>> If you can't see the live
interactity, please click on the
blue join live interactive
experience button on the Web
site and we'll see you on the
other side.
From those of you just joining
us from the spotlight session,
you heard about some of our new
product announcements, including
Anthos for VMs, Anthos
multi-cloud API and the Google
distributed cloud.
>> Awesome.
In the next 15 minutes, we're
actually going to show you all
of these in action, which is
great.
So here's what we're going to do
together.
First, we're going to migrate
something and demonstrate how to
get some new value from an old
system by moving VM-based
applications to a newer
containerized platform.
And we'll start by showing you
how to run a legacy app in a
serverless platform.
So buckle up.
>> Next, we'll create.
We'll build a new experience for
customers through our AI-powered
software, and then we'll deploy
with some brand new deployment
tools unique to Google Cloud.
>> Love it.
Finally, we're going to be
expanding our deployment
targets.
We're not just shipping to cloud
anymore, but extending that
awesome path to production to
other public clouds, and even
closer to your customers at the
edge.
All right.
So let's bring some things up,
shall we?
And now work at Cymbal shops.
So let's pretend that I am the
director of IT at this company,
Cymbal shops, and like many of
you, our global business has
been shifted because of
increasing demands online, and
at the same time we have some
problems, so old software was
never meant for all the customer
loads we're putting on it now.
It's holding us back.
We're trying to offer mobile
experiences, real-time stuff, we
have to do it as quick as we
can, and look, I can't rewrite
everything.
So how do we reduce some costs
and add some capabilities to
that existing software, a little
easier, without too much effort?
So I want to start with a smart
migration approach, you know, I
want a repeatable, efficient way
to move old systems to newer
stuff, maybe even a serverless
one.
But Cymbalshop needs help from
our friends at Google Cloud.
Help, you're my only hope.
>> I got you, Richard.
So our fit assessment tool,
which you can see here, is
initiated from the Google Cloud
console.
It helps us understand what can
be automatically migrated and
which workloads are going to be
most successful in their new
home.
It's unique to Google Cloud and
saves you time.
By pointing our migrate service
at a set of over 2,000 virtual
machines in our on-prem
environment, we just generated a
fit assessment for the workloads
running in each of those VMs.
And remember, these VMs could be
running on prem, in Google
Cloud, in AWS or in Azure.
So now, let's take a look at the
result of the assessment.
See here, we have a graphical
view of our most likely
candidates for migration.
This tool is particularly good
at detecting compatibility for
older java applications like
java, EE application servers.
Now, that we've assessed, let's
migr
migrate.
Using our migrate service, I'm
taking a java app, running on
Web sphere in an on-prem VM, and
generating a container image.
That can run on any of our
container services, all via
automation.
And, you can see here that the
classic java app is now served
up by our only pay for what you
use serverless container
product, Cloud Run.
>> Wow.
I love that.
So this is great.
I want to make sure we know what
we just did here.
I mean, I don't have to manage
all of these partially utilized
virtual machines anymore because
you containerized it, and I've
offloaded some of the
management.
That's awesome.
And you've given me access to
brand new functionality and
saved me money by running in a
modern platform like Cloud Run,
so you just took a classic java
app and ran that on a serverless
platform.
That's pretty wild stuff.
If you like that, tell us in the
chat that you have a need for
putting some of your older
systems in these newer
platforms.
All right.
So next up, let's create some
new value and get that to Google
Cloud.
So SiCymbal shop has some probls
that we have to solve.
It needs some serious
modernization to support all of
those sort of new customer
experiences and keep us
competitive.
So this means upgrading
functionality and even changing
how we could deliver it to
production.
So curbside pickup, super hot
right now.
How do I add functionality then
to count how many customers did
curbside pickup each day.
That seems really important.
Can you help me with this one?
>> Yes, of course, I can.
So Richard, what does your
current app consist of?
>> Well, thank you for asking.
Our current app has a MongoDB
database with multiple services
that track orders and pickups.
We actually want to add new
services and data to capture and
analyze that curbside pickup
info, and to make that happen,
we could look at historical
footage from the past day and
count the pickups and do some
analysis later.
>> This looks like a great
opportunity to do two things.
First, we're going to add Google
Cloud AI to process video
footage and capture metrics.
Second, we'll containerize these
workloads and put them on a
continuous delivery pipeline so
that it's easy to keep making
changes.
>> I like that.
So if you do this, then we
actually know how many customers
are doing curbside pickup, maybe
even how long they were waiting,
and I think you're going to fix
some of my path to prod and make
it easy to kind of package and
keep changing the software over
and over again.
I love that.
>> Yes.
Absolutely.
Check it out.
So Google Cloud vision API can
detect vehicles in this footage
to determine how well curbside
pickups have been going at each
location.
So now, let's write some code,
and deploy the updated app to
Google Cloud.
This is exciting, and I'm hoping
all our audience is excited,
too.
I'm using visual studio code
here, but I could easily use
intellij or any IDE.
And using the no-cost cloud code
plug-in, I can easily browse
Google Cloud services, add them
to my app, and then code and
test this container-based app.
>> You are the fastest coder
I've ever seen.
That was remarkable.
So that was pretty simple, too.
I like that.
So now that everything is
working locally, how would I
then deploy this to the cloud?
>> Let me show you.
First, we need to package up
this app into a container.
You probably want your
developers spending time writing
code, not docker files, and we
can help with that.
I'll show you how we like to
package containers, and while
I'm doing that audience, tell us
how do you package your
containers?
So here is our poll, and we have
four options in our poll, so I'm
hoping you would actually pick
it up.
>> Awesome.
>> So Cloud Build is a
serverless build tool that many
customers use for continuous
integration.
We also now support industry
standard cloud build-backs to
package up our app into a
container image automaticably
and send it to artifact reg
y
registry.
It stores your container images
in regional repositories and
here you see that we
automatically scan for
vulnerabilities.
>> That's neat.
What else do we use artifact
registry for?
I haven't seen as much about
that.
Can you tell me a little bit
about that?
>> Yeah.
So while we use artifact
registry for storing docker
container images, Richard, we
can also use it for storing all
your language-specific artifacts
in one place.
For instance, we just went GA
with java, no t.js.
>> That's pretty cool.
So while we're waiting for the
poll results, looking at some of
the chat, I saw some questions
about how do we do day 2
management of migrated
workloads.
I think the migrate tooling
gives you a container image that
now I could download to my desk
top, I can run in different
places.
I have different ways to run
that.
Some other questions about,
again, thinking about how do we
migrate to GKE and Cloud Run.
I think it's pretty cool that
they can take an app and run it
in either one, which I think is
great, and we're seeing the poll
results come in.
>> Yeah.
Looks like the results are in.
And it's amazing that a lot of
folks are already automating
today and they are automating
via docker build commands in CI
pipeline.
That's excellent.
So now that we have a container
in the registry, I think it's
time to deploy it.
So to deploy our app, let's use
the new Google Cloud deploy
service, a continuous delivery
service for deploying
containerized workloads.
While the service is
containerized and could run in
GKE or Cloud Run, the app is
fairly coupled to our MongoDB
infrastructure running in
Kubernetes and is part of our
multi-cloud strategy.
So let's target one of our GKE
auto pilot clusters.
GKE auto pilot is the full y
managed service where Google
Cloud provisions, scales,
upgrades and troubleshoots the
cluster for me.
Here we see a deployment
pipeline that helps us manage
release candidates and
environments.
Cloud deploy helps us manage
promotion and rollout across
these environments, and once the
app is deployed to GKE auto
pilot, you can start using it
from each retail store that you
ha
have.
You kick this all off and also
you manually approve final
promotion to production.
In fact, I'm going to have
someone drop the URL in the chat
window now so that you can see
it for yourself.
It all works just like magic.
>> That's cool.
That's great.
So it's awesome.
So from development to packaging
to deployment, I think
personally this is the best set
of integrated tools for services
and building containers that
I've seen, so I think that's
awesome.
So we're also seeing some other
folks in the chat talking about
some of these components as well
and what they're seeing for
migrating the apps, and
hopefully clicking links and
trying to break the app we just
deployed.
All right.
So now that we've just taken
that existing app, we added AI
functionality and we
dramatically changed the
knowledge that each of our
stores has about the customer
experience.
That's pretty cool.
>> Indeed, isn't it, Richard?
What else do you want to throw
my way?
>> I think we got some time.
So we've acquired a few other
retail chains who use different
clouds.
I mean, nobody's perfect, right?
So at the same time, this app
needs to run in more places so
that each of those stores can
analyze curbside pickup
behavior, regardless of what
cloud they're using, so how do I
run this app everywhere?
>> Yeah, that's a great
question, Richard, and we do
have a solution for consistency
across any environment.
Check out how we do it through
Anthos.
With the new multi-cloud API, we
can provision these clusters
right from the Google Cloud CLI
or console in other clouds,
including AWS and Azure, where
you already had some
applications installed.
See here that I'm using a single
G-cloud command to create a GKE
cluster on Azure.
Here, we've deployed GKE
clusters to Google Cloud, and
Microsoft azuAzure.
I'm managing it all from Google
Cloud, and I'm even able to
centrally deploy and view
workloads to any of these GKE
clusters.
>> That's wild.
Thanks.
So you're actually putting GKE,
I think it's the best Kubernetes
in the public cloud anywhere I
wanted, and that's really
powerful stuff.
I love that new Azure support.
And again, each store manager,
whatever cloud they're using can
actually see the support at the
end of the day to know how they
performed on curbside pickup.
That was the goal.
All right.
So now you're making me think
that we could probably do more.
We could expand some of our
thinking here and maybe respond
to the customers' demands in
real time.
Could we evolve from that
analysis of parking lot footage
to maybe improve the experience
in real-time?
By that I'm thinking, can I run
this AI model against live
camera footage instead of
recorded stuff and maybe be able
to do something with it as it
happens?
But of course, as always, new
challenges emerge, if we think
of something like this, so off
the top of my head, we'd have to
somehow customize this AI model,
right?
Because now I have to identify
the number of cars in motion,
how many are waiting, is the
curbside lot picking up, and I
probably want to operationalize
that model and move it closer to
the store, because I'm
processing data in real time, so
latency matters.
And then I want to integrate all
that insight I'm getting with
the existing in-store systems
for the managers to use so they
can move their employees around.
So that's a lot of stuff.
I don't know.
Can you help me with that?
>> We can.
So I'm calling in my colleague,
Gabri
Gabrielle.
He has been working with one of
your on-prem locations, Richard,
in Austin, and he can explain
how we improve your software for
edge scenarios.
Hi, Gabrielle.
>> Hi.
Hey, everyone.
Glad to join you, Richard.
By the way, congrats on your new
role.
What you're asking for can be
summed up with Google
distributed cloud and the edge.
It builds the best of Google
Cloud to the edge.
It consists of a fully managed
CPU, GPU optimized platform with
a common set of Google interpret
applications.
It can be deployed anywhere.
As an example here, at some of
your stores.
So let's get going.
We're going to add real-time
intelligence with AI models, and
process locally to reduce video
latency.
Let's get this running on the
edge in each store.
So we start out by first using
Google Vertex AI, so we train
the engines and the visual AI
objects, recent specification
models in the central cloud.
Here, we are monitoring the
progress and accuracy of the
mod
model, and as you can see, the
trained models cannot -- those
container images can be ready to
be deployed anywhere, including
in the edge.
In this case, we'll be targeting
five different Cymbal stores.
From the Google console, we can
choose the Kubernetes clusters
run specific edge locations
across all the single stores.
Once we've picked those
clusters, we can deploy the
visual AI model we created to
each edge in the store, and
manage those edge clusters just
like any other GKE clusters.
The Cymbal operations team has
the same familiar experience,
only now, Cymbal can also
leverage the GPU optimized to
cloud to achieve better
performance and lower latency.
And as a fully managed service,
we see that Cloud comes with the
same integrated Google Cloud
operation and management
capabilities that you're used
to.
Here, you know, Cymbal can
monitor the health and state of
their store deployments, manage
capacity scale, all of these
using a familiar Google console
and backed by Google SRE
practices.
So as you can see in the video
here, a real-time analysis of
curbside service level from the
live footage led to real-time
insight for single shops to
build a better customer
experience at each store.
Specific provision model in the
edge is recognizing cars motion,
to recognize when the curbside
spots are filling up, or
continual time.
So what do you think, Richard?
Back to you.
>> This is great.
You're amazing, Gabrielle.
That's -- I can't believe you
built all that all by yourself.
So this actually gives all our
store managers really new
insight into the real-time
customer experience, letting
those stores allocate staff and
people based on real-time
customer demand.
That's awesome.
So for the audience out there,
I'm actually interested, what
sort of apps do you think about
running at the edge?
Is that a real use case you're
considering?
What sort of things might run
there?
All right.
So I do love what you built for
me.
I don't want to be, you know,
greedy, but I want a little
more.
This app isn't an island, right?
You're doing some cool AI
containerized based stuff, but
there's a lot of things already
at that store location, right?
Our notification services,ory
back office, it's all in VM's.
So now that we have to integrate
our new AI customer service app,
these VM-based systems, am I
signing up for completely
different management experiences
across containers and virtual
machines, or can you do
something for me?
>> Oh, absolutely not.
We're going to provide you the
same experience, with the new
Anthos for VMs.
We can actually help you bring
those virtual machines into the
Anthos platform and manage them
the same way you manage
containers.
So see here, I've moved several
virtual machines under Anthos
management, which now gives me a
straightforward way to move and
modernize existing apps at the
edge.
>> Wow.
That's awesome.
There's nothing you can't do,
Gra
Gabrielle, that's great.
So what's powerful here is that
all the Google powered fleet
management in Google Cloud,
other clouds, at the edge, is
all based on Anthos with one
open control plane for wherever
those workloads run.
This simplifies our operations a
lot.
That open foundation makes
hiring developers a heck of a
lot easier.
So last challenge for you,
Cymbal has this growing European
presence, but they operate on
restrictions on data
sovereignty.
I don't want to sacrifice all
the amazing capabilities that
you've showed me today, or is
this a lost cause, or do you
have something for me?
>> Yes, we have something for
you.
As we announced yesterday,
within Google Google Cloud, we
can use a single hardware and
software stack from Google
Cloud, but now local compute,
and in local control plane.
It runs not only our container
and VM workloads, but also the
data and application services we
care about.
We could run these as an example
in the regional holster, fully
air gapped and have local stores
connect directly to that.
One open modern platform from
wherever you want to operate.
>> I'm sold.
You've done it.
So it's pretty cool.
So same Anthos control plane
tech, but also local services in
this fully air gap setting.
That's great stuff.
Thanks, Gabrielle.
Appreciate you joining us here.
Did you like that?
>> I did, actually.
And Gabrielle, that was amazing,
and I'm sure audience thinks so
as well.
Over the last 15 minutes, we've
shown you how Google Cloud
offers a world-class experience
for building new software or
modernizing what you have.
Our solutions for
container-based apps are second
to none, and they're now making
it possible to extend those
terrific services to wherever
you need us to be.
>> All right.
Thank you all for joining us.
This was terrific stuff.
And thank you out there for the
chat and the engagement.
It was awesome to see that.
So now, stay tuned for the live
Q&A coming up next.
We're going to talk about
everything from the spotlight
all the way through to this
demo.
Get your questions in there, and
we'll be answering it live.
Thanks so much.
Bye-bye.
>> Bye.
>> All right.
Hi, it's me again.
In case you didn't tune in for
that live demo that just wrapped
up, I'm Richard.
>> I'm Sachin.
Richard, it's nice to see you in
your new role.
>> Yeah, thanks for hiring me
back, I'm glad to be back.
So our friends from the live
demo are going to be sticking
around to answer any of the
questions you may have, so you
may see their faces throughout
the show as well, so let's jump
in with a little poll.
What gets you fired up about
tech, using serverless
platforms, running GKE anywhere?
How about continuously building
software, or heck, even just
having breakfast for dinner.
Throw your results in there.
I'd love to see what you have to
say.
So while we wait for that, are a
reminder, this Q&A is completely
live.
You can engage with us directly,
ask your questions, say hi in
the chat, yell at us, certainly
Sachin, not me, I'm doing my
best.
If you can't, though, go back to
that Web site, and we'll wait
for you over here.
All right.
Now time for some poll results.
Let's see what we have.
Anything coming so far, let's
see what fires people up.
What fires you up, Sachin?
>> Well, besides breakfast for
dinner, it's all about Google
distributed cloud.
The ability to have that
consistent management running
anywhere, meekt our customers
where they're at, fully managed
solutions, it's just absolutely
incredible, and with Gabrielle,
that was just fantastic.
>> Yeah, it's a big deal.
Well, looking at the results so
far, you all are just animals.
Eating breakfast for dinner.
So good job.
>> I was right.
>> Yeah.
Live your life.
That's great.
So let's get started with our
first question.
This one comes from Jessica.
So when would I use Anthos on
bare metal infrastructure versus
that Google distributed cloud at
edge, how do I make the decision
between the two?
>> Yeah, that's a great
question.
Thanks for that question.
So first of all, let me just go
back to that Cymbal shops retail
example.
If you're a customer, you have
your own hardware, it's
customized for that environment,
perhaps, and you're just looking
for a stack on top to run,
Anthos bare metal is a great
option.
But if you're a customer where
you just want to consume the
whole stack, hardware, software,
as a service, and you want to
leave all that complexity to us,
then the Google distributed
cloud product is a great
solution for that and so we want
to be very flexible about it.
You get to choose based on what
your needs are.
>> It's nice to have the
software-based option or the
software and hardware.
>> Exactly.
Exactly.
Because, you know, different --
>> The same control plane.
>> But the same control plane,
same experience.
Deploy -- write ones, build
ones, deploy anywhere.
>> Yeah, that's a big deal.
So this one is going to be for
you, Sachin, as well.
So this one comes from Mike.
Wl, you know, Val is asking this
question, let's switch questions
up.
I'll give you a breather.
I wore you out on that one.
So are there other managed
services that people might want
to adopt as they become more
cloud native?
When did they start picking up
as they start making this move
to cloud?
>> Yeah.
Absol
Absolutely, Richard.
So as you deploy more
micro services, you can easily
leverage our fully managed
serverless cork stration
products like work flows or
event to arc so that you can
connect as well as coordinate
Google Cloud services such as
cloud functions, Cloud Run, HTTP
based, API services, including
third party services so that you
can all tie them all up in to
serverless work flows, and this
really helps you address those
type of use cases which require
business critical, mission
critical work flows so that you
can actually have in built error
handling, retries, observability
built in so that everything
actually executes reliably and
flawlessly.
>> Love it.
Thank you.
Good.
Next one, this one is for you,
Sachin.
Buckle up here.
So Robert from Liberty Mutual is
asking us about kind of the OS
support for Anthos.
So when I think about, you know,
we know Anthos spoerpts windows
sxn Linux, which is great, so
he's curious about where are we
at with some of the operating
systems?
>> This is consistent with the
Anthos that you have from a
software only point of view, but
with Google distributed cloud,
we just carried it forward.
We're certifying that solution
on top of hardware that they
prescribe.
And I think there was a question
that I was seeing in chat, which
is about, hey, you know, what
kind of hardware is certified.
So we've gone in, we have
hardware from Dell, from HPE,
we've got GPU's, and so there's
different hardware for different
scenarios, and then on top of
that, whatever Anthos provides,
we can bring to bear.
>> You can run -- we support all
of those as well, so we try to
give you a good set of choices
there.
Awesome.
Let's do it.
So are you seeing any customer
preference so far for GKE auto
pilot versus GKE standard?
GKE standard is amazing, it's
got all the knobs and dials.
Auto pilots just turn key.
Ready to go.
Are you seeing any change in
preferences?
>> First of all, we've seen
massive adoption of GKE auto
pilot, so it's really opened the
door, I think, for many, many
customers who wanted to get the
benefit of Kubernetes and
containers, but wanted it to be
sort of automatically set up for
them.
But you still have customers who
don't just want that Kubernetes
API.
They actually want to have an
existing cluster or to have an
environment that's fine-tuned
for their needs, very, very
large scale deployment where GKE
works great.
And so I think with the
combination of GKE and GKE auto
pilot, we can now cater to any
of those needs.
>> Yeah, I guess we've actually
seen a lot of auto pilot
customers or just new Google
Cloud customers as well.
A great first foray in to
Kubernetes.
>> Exactly.
Exactly.
They can get going so quickly.
I mean, again, the demos just
now were fantastic.
>> Yeah, even I can use it.
Great stuff.
More stuff, Sachin.
How do I choose which container
oriented compute service to use?
Now, we don't necessarily have
the 17 ways that other clouds
offer.
We have maybe fewer, more
focused services, but there are
more choices, not just one way
to run a container, so how
should one make a decision
there?
>> We do keep it simple, but
there are some choices.
If you have something that's
compute heavy, where it's a lot
of self-managed software that
you have, self managed services
that you're creating, it could
be that you have your own
datab
databases, it could be a middle
ware messaging.
That's where we think GKE is
best.
But if you're a consumer of a
lot of the managed services and
you've got some adjacent code
that complements those services,
then Cloud Run is fantastic.
And so not the 17 locuses like
you mentioned, but there are few
choices based on how you're
using that containerized
environment.
>> Yeah.
That's a crisp way of thinking
about it.
Good stuff.
Spencer is asking us, you know,
Anthos for VM's is interesting.
We announced that, and that
seems wild.
We've just been talking
containers at this time.
Now we're talking VM.
So what in the world is the use
case for that?
Why in the world would I think
about having Anthos manage
virtual machines?
>> Once again, great question.
We've been very clear about
this.
We want to meet customers where
they're at, and while customers
are looking to modernize, and
want to be on GKE, on
Kubernetes, containerized, they
do have some software
components, some applications
that require the environment.
And so the ability to have that
one consistent management plane,
and have the sort of lowered
cost running have.
M's or containers on top of
Kubernetes, that's a very
powerful combination.
So Anthos for VMs is just while
they're looking to mentorize,
whatever pieces of software they
have that requires software,
they can bring it along
consistently as they do the
transition.
>> It seems powerful to get
maybe the operational tool
chain, just treat the VM
containers the same way, that
way they can simplify management
and hiring and those sorts of
things.
>> Yeah.
Exactly.
If they're going to be there
next to the containers, that's
great, but that consistent
management reduces the
operational cost.
>> This one is going to go to
Vidia, so Alex is asking us
about Cloud Run, and look this
is something that we talk a lot
about.
We love Cloud Run.
Cloud Run is terrific.
So what's new and interesting
there.
What's been happening in the
Cloud Run world?
>> Yeah.
Thanks, Richard.
So here are some new features
that might be interesting.
Number one, to further secure
your Cloud Run environment, we
just spent GA with binary
authorizations so that you can
deploy your trusted container
images.
Number two, you can now run even
more workloads, for instance
workloads that may need
background processing, and we
offered additional always-on CPU
allocation controls, which comes
with new pricing.
There are no requests fees,
memory and CPU's about 25
percent lower priced.
The third feature that might be
interesting to call out is that
while Cloud Run free tier
continues to exist, we also now
recently introduced committed
use discounts so that you can
actually get up to 17 percent
discount for over a one-year
commitment.
>> That's great.
Awesome.
Thanks, Vidia.
Yeah.
I think some of that committed
use stuff is terrific.
Same with the security features.
I mean, Cloud Run is one of the
best security oriented just
container run times out there,
in addition with GKE.
Another question, this one is
for you again, Sachin.
I'm glad you're ready.
Vladimir is asking us, what is
the benefit of doing Anthos edge
versus Anthos on VMware?
And I know those are even
different to start with as we
think about the question, could
you do on VMware at the edge?
You know, how do you think about
then our distributed cloud edge.
I guess kind of help demystify
this.
>> If I think about the
question, it feels a little bit
similar to the previous
question, which is what are you
actually trying to do?
If you're actually trying to
modernize, then the Anthos
environment, where we provide
that simple management plane,
built on Kubernetes, where, you
know, you can run containerized
applications, but you can also
run VMs now, that's a you're on
a path to modernization.
That's what you're looking for.
You're looking for operational
cost reduction, simplification,
but you want to be into this
sort of new world in the
containerized world, that's
where -- but there are going to
be other options on prem that
you can run.
And then similar to, you know,
perhaps other solutions that may
be out there where it's not just
a software layer, you can
package the hardware and the
software completely together,
that's where Google distributed
cloud, that's built on Anthos,
comes together.
So are you looking to modernize?
Is it just a pure legacy
environment that that's how it's
going to remain?
If you're looking for modernize
and you need the flexibility of
having MV's as well, Anthos and
Anthos for VMs is perfect.
>> And obviously you can run
right on top of that and
everything is amazing so again I
like the flexibility that we'll
work with what you have.
>> And if you want to run that
VM footprint inside our Google
Cloud regions, for that we've
Google Cloud VM region, and we
support that.
And so we're very flexible based
on what customers are trying to
achieve.
>> Yeah.
Awesome.
Another one for you, Sachin.
This one I think is interesting.
So I thought Anthos was already
multi-cloud.
What are we talking about with a
multi-cloud API.
Weren't we already doing that?
Or what's new with a multi-cloud
API?
>> Yes.
Look, Anthos has been
multi-cloud for over a year now,
right?
So the multi-cloud API is really
about instead of having to bring
up your clusters, your GKE
clusters, the control plane as
well in every single cloud, you
can now just run that control
plane in Google Cloud, and then
manage those clusters that may
be sitting in, you know,
somewhere else, in a very, very
simple way through that same
control plane, and so it's
further simplifying how you
deploy those clusters and how
you manage them, and bringing
you the power of GKE and Anthos
together.
>> Yeah.
No, I love that demo of just
showing a single G-cloud command
because for someone today you
could deploy Anthos on AWS, but
you first stand up that
management cluster.
It wasn't hard, but can I
simplify that, can we take more
responsibility, and it looks
like we have, so I think it's
really just a simplification
story.
Awesome.
This one is for me somehow.
So awesome.
So how do I choose between GKE
auto pilot and Cloud Run?
Look, auto pilot is amazing.
It feels like serverless
Kubernetes, and that's kind of
magic on how that behaves, and
it's still Kubernetes under
cover.
There's no extra extension
stuff, this is just GKE.
And Cloud Run is also kind of a
serverless environment.
So if you look at the difference
between the two, really it's
about, to some extent, do I want
Kubernetes?
If I'm deploying marketplace
offerings, I'm deploying a
database, I'm deploying stateful
workloads, auto pilot is going
to be amazing there.
Right?
So that one is pretty powerful.
And then at the same time, if
I'm in Cloud Run, and as you
mentioned earlier, right, if
I've got a lot of managed
services, I'm using spanner,
Pub/Sub, I'm doing AI and
putting some code in the gaps to
connect the dots to add some API
end points, Cloud Run is
amazing.
So when I look at this, when I
look at customers, it's often a
case where if I want Kubernetes,
GKE is clearly a great choice.
If I'm building compute intense
systems, as you mentioned
earlier, GKE is amazing, and
auto pilot is awesome, and when
I'm just trying to run some
containers and building things
that kind of connect dots
between other managed services,
Cloud Run is best in class.
>> Yeah.
It depends on your starting
point, I guess.
>> Yeah.
But again, not too many choices,
but just enough.
Awesome.
This is another one for Sachin.
This one is coming from Ford
Motor Company folks.
Is Anthos open source?
Is there any support available?
Is this just DIY, live your
life, or are we actually behind
the product helping people, this
is commercial offering.
Help clear that up.
>> Yeah, first of all, in terms
of open source, it's built on
Kubernetes.
And so built on open source
components, so for sure, it
enables our first-party software
on top, but also third-party
open source software that can
run in that containerized or VM
environment.
As far as support, it's been --
we now have more and more
partners, more and more
customers trained on Anthos.
Anthos is the foundation of
Google distributed cloud as
well, and so we continue to
invest heavily to ensure that
the training, the enablement,
the skills, the capabilities,
get built up in our customers,
in our partners, to continue to
support those deployments.
I don't know if you want to add
to that.
>> No, it's a great answer.
I mean, we see so many people
take all this amazing open
source and build platforms,
which can be powerful, and
Anthos is actually 30-something
odd open source projects that
come in to one curated,
integrated, tested, packaged
commercial product, as you say,
and the multi-cloud support is a
best effort.
We test this and certify it on
as zur, on Amazon, on prem, on
metal, so I think that's pretty
powerful stuff that, you know, I
think some people can still get
a little bit like what in the
world is Anthos, and I think
it's important for us to remind
people that Anthos is really a
way to build and manage
distributed fleets of
infrastructure, and so what a
powerful way to do that in a
supported fashion.
>> Yeah, hybrid, multi-cloud,
with hardware, software
together.
>> How do I manage a bunch of
GKE clusters all over the place.
That's a really powerful,
hopeful, simple way to
understand this sort of thing.
Have you continued to see that
uptick as well in Anthos?
I know we're starting to see
some of the growth there.
Are you happy with where things
are going?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
We continue to see more customer
traction, and now with Anthos,
Anthos for VM's, Anthos for bare
metal.
>> Putting in distributed cloud
is powerful story for customers,
because I can make one
investment in my skills and now
I can take advantage of this in
a lot of places.
>> Yes.
>> Awesome.
So next we want to go to Fabian.
So Fabian is asking, what,
containers are all over the
place, should I just opt for
Cloud Run instead of App Engine?
Wlees the future of App Engine
in this context.
Vidia, what have you got for me?
>> Yeah.
So App Engine is obviously a
very successful product for us
at Google and serverless.
However, we see containers as
very, very strong positioned for
the future of development, as
you could see with all the demos
that we had, and with technology
such as Cloud Run, as well as
GKE auto pilot that has come in
to play, it has got the benefits
of portability and better
integrations with the rest of
GCP, as well as the cloud.
So that's the way we look at it.
>> That seems like a good
answer.
I mean, you know, Google Cloud's
got a lot of these stable
services, a lot of customers on
App Engine, but it's nice to
have alternates as people are
looking for other integrations,
things like that.
Cloud Run is continuing to be a
big investment.
That's awesome.
Sachin, this one's for you.
Security questions.
I mean, I was personally
impressed with a lot of it and
enjoyed a lot of the keynotes
from yesterday as we looked at
all the investments we're making
in security here.
If you're trying to make a
choice on security, I think
Google Cloud is your best
choice, and not just because I
work here.
But how secure are some of these
clusters out of the box?
We're thinking about, I'm
assuming this refers to Anthos.
You know, when we stick either
an Anthos cluster or a GKE
cluster off prem or even just a
GKE cluster sitting in Google
Cloud, how do you think about
the security store and how
secure is this by default?
>> By default what we're trying
to do is turn on all the best
practices that we recommend so
that the communication channel
that you described is secure if
customers want to manage that
with their own case, they can,
but we want to make sure that
all the best practices, so that
if it's -- the data is in
transit, the data is at rest,
then by default we can keep that
on for customers.
I mean, you should add some more
Anthos-specific, maybe security
capabilities that we turn on.
>> Yeah, as you say, there's a
lot of important things around
OS hardening, how we distribute
bytes.
They're coming from us.
You can trust that as well that
we're putting them through the
paces, but then with auto pilot,
arguably one of the best parts
of auto pilot is that we just
enable all the security stuff by
default, because I don't know
what I'm doing as an end user
myself when I send up stuff, so
if you're turning on the right
sort of encryption at rest
settings, you're tongue on all
the right access, you're turning
on continual updates for
patching, I think that's pretty
awesome.
So in a lot of these cases we're
defaulting to secure.
>> I think one of the questions
we get is how do you handle this
in the air gap environment.
Like, so how does the customer
get software updates, how do
they make those secure.
And so what we do is we take
that software, we publish it to
a repository.
The customer is able to download
it outside their air gap, check
it for any vulnerabilities, you
know, test it out on their own,
and then move it into the air
gap, and then the platform will
automatically deploy it, and so
there's some additional checks
that they're able to add when
they have those very strict
sovereignty data privacy needs,
and they need to be able to
check any piece of software
that's coming down.
>> Powerful stuff.
All right.
Last question for you.
I could ask you questions all
day, but I'm being told I have
to ask you a last question.
>> Okay.
>> So John wants to know as
well, so I'm assuming this
refers as well to distributed
cloud.
Whose hardware is this and who
does it run on, and do you
manage the hardware platform as
well?
Let's at least refer to
distributed cloud.
Are we managing the hardware?
Is it coming from Google?
Are we making the kits, or is it
coming from partners?
Lay that out for us real quick.
>> Yeah, so it's prescriptive
hardware that we provide, and we
manage.
Right?
And so in terms of how it's
supported, again, that's done
through us.
We can do this through partners
as well, and so what happens is
in a -- for example in air gap,
in the hosted mode, you may need
to have a trusted partner -- or
customer may want a trusted
partner who's actually doing the
operations in terms of hey, I'm
adding a rack, or adding more
hardware components, but the
software that they provide
manages that hardware
infrastructure that's deployed
on prem, and the beauty of it is
the controlled plane there is
completely disconnected from
Google Cloud as well.
So you have both those options,
you know, the edge mode where
it's connected, we can do it
centrally across many sites, or
hosted, where the control plane
is local, but we still manage
the hardware.
>> Super powerful stuff.
Love that.
So thank you, Sachin.
Thanks to all of our guests who
we threw questions to on the
demo set.
So it's been awesome hearing
from you all, getting all that
feedback.
Be sure to hop over to the cloud
Next site and stay tuned for
Phil and Sunil talking about
security.
Thank you.
>> Hi, there.
Thanks for all the participation
in our Q&A, and I hope you're
enjoying the show.
So welcome to Security
Spotlight.
My name is Sunil Potti, and I'm
the VP and GM for Google Cloud
Security.
Over the last few months, we've
seen some of the most damaging
cyber attacks in history, you
know, against public utilities,
private sector companies,
government agencies.
Causing many organizations to
realize they are at a pivotal
moment in their security
journey.
Of course, this is not news to
you know most of you in our
industry, but let me put a few
things in context with a
sobering statistic.
Did you know that the cost of
cybercrime is now estimated
between 2 and 10 trillion
dollars a year?
For the past two decades, Google
has made security the corner
stone of our strategy.
This has resulted in Google
enabling more users to be safe
than anyone else in the world,
locking malware, phishing
attempts, spam, cyber attacks
globally, and not just for a few
thousands of Web sites, but for
billions of users and millions
of Web sites globally.
So that being said, we also
realized that this journey, you
know, will require enduring
commitment over the coming
years.
And that's why Google is
committed to invest $10 billion
for the next five years to help
strengthen cyber security for
enterprises, consumers and
governments.
We want you to be able to use
our Google Cloud Security magic
to protect your enterprise.
We make that possible in two
ways.
First, we provide the industry's
most trusted cloud for
accelerating your digital
transformation efforts, and
secondly, we bring trust to you
with security products that meet
you where you are, and bring our
Google security magic to your
on-prem, private and multi-cloud
environments.
And it's just not about having
best-in-class security
capabilities.
It's also about how they are
actually delivered in a
consumerized fashion.
But at Google Cloud, we take a
different approach.
We are driven by a vision of
invisible security, where
security technologies are
engineered in, so you get
opinionated full-stack coverage
of security controls, security
operations as a silo disappears,
so niche security talent gets
democratized.
And last, but quite
significantly, shared
responsibility in a world of
public cloud evolves to shared
Fate, where we, as your
provider, have true skin in the
game, and mutual security
outcomes.
So a great example of what I
mean by invisible security is
the all-new, built-in data
protection, automatic DLP for
BigQuery.
It's a game-changing capability
that discovers and classifies
sensitive data for all of BQ
project across your entireorg
without you needing to do a
single thing.
If you take a full step back and
internalize what invisible
security could mean for you, as
an enterprise, a service
provider, a partner, or whoever
it is, there are three areas
where Google's insight and
experience can make a meaningful
difference.
One, protecting your employees
and assets.
Two, protecting your IP.
Three, protecting your users and
your brand.
Let me spend a bit of time on
each of these.
First, one of the most overused
buzz words in cyber security
today is zero trust.
Why not?
The core of the zero trust
approach is the idea that
implicit trust in any single
component of a complex,
interconnected system can create
serious security risks.
What does that mean?
It's that trust needs to be
established via multiple
mechanisms, and be verified
continuously.
So here at Google, we have
applied a zero trust approach to
most aspects of our operations.
We've implemented zero trust
access with our BeyondCorp
framework, shared our use case
with the entire world, and
delivered BeyondCorp enterprise,
a world class solution that
includes integrated threat and
data protection.
We've had great reception to be
on corp enterprise since the
launch earlier this year, and
today we're delivering
capabilities that expand the
surface area for zero trust
access to cover all of your
apps, both modern, as well as
legacy.
So as a point of note, right
after this session, the team
will be doing a live end-to-end
demo of BeyondCorp Enterprise to
show how you can make access
easier and more secure the
Google way.
So don't miss it.
Next, protecting your assets is
easier if it's intentionally
done upstream, shifting security
left.
And so zero trust goes beyond
access to protecting your
workloads as well and your IP.
And how Google operates our
production environment is in
this way, the way software is
conceived, produced, managed and
interacts with other software.
We call that approach
BeyondProd, and we've already
productized many capabilities
for you.
So looking at BeyondCorp and
BeyondProd, you realize that
zero trust is much more than
tools.
Zero trust is how we envision
designing, deploying and
operating safe environments so
our daily lives, as an
enterprise or consumer, can go
from a world of being on the
edge to being safe.
And safer with Google.
But you can't lose sight of the
fact that while zero trust
approaches help, you know,
address the preventative side of
your program, robust detection
and response capabilities are
needed to complete the
Equa
Equation.
And this is why we invest in
chronicle, and we
continue to amplify it as our
foundational security operation
solution.
And we are excited to announce
stronger integration between
Chronicle and Security Command
Center, SCC on GCP with
centralization of alerts, the
addition of cloud asset and
management, and user context to
enrich investigations.
Next, let's talk a little bit
about protecting your
intellectual property.
So for organizations pursuing
digital transformation, code is
your IP.
It's the heart of your business.
The foundation of securing your
code is a secure software supply
chain.
From the time developers start
writing code through your CI/CD
pipeline all the way through
deploying and operating in
production.
So at Google Cloud, we believe
two things are foundationally
necessary for doing this in an
enduring fashion.
One, industry wide frameworks
and standards are a must, but
they also need to be
complemented by full stack
managed services that implement
these standards and make
adoption easy.
So for the first, Google
cofounded open SSF across
industry forum for open source
and supply chains software
security.
Projects such as SLSA, an
end-to-end framework for
Ens
Enduring the integrity of
software artifacts.
And second, we have the all-star
GitHub app, right, in time for
the fall season.
For continuous enforcement of
best practices for GitHub
projects.
And then last but not least,
open Source Score Cards, which
provide a risk score for open
source projects.
And this is just a few ways
Google is contributing to
industry-wide standards.
And on Google Cloud, with our
invisible security approach, we
provide these tools in a fully
managed environment, from code
to build, deploy, run and
operate that implement these
standards by default.
And let's not forget, you also
get a consistent way to define
and enforce policy for a zero
trust software supply chain that
establishes prominence and
prevents modification or
tampering.
And we're building this zero
trust software supply chain with
new additions across the board.
You can learn more about all of
these launches in our breakout
sessions.
So to add some more, you know,
context to this with new voices
in our conversation on these
topics, I'd like to bring on
Murray from Facebook, and Steph,
who leads our cloud security
user experience team.
Steph and Murray, over to you.
>> Thanks Sunil, and welcome,
Murray!
Can you tell us about your role
at Facebook and what that work
entails?
>> Sure.
I'm a manager supporting the
Cloud foundation team within
Facebook.
Cloud foundation is chartered to
help teams with a need to use
public Clouds for their
workloads so that they can do so
both quickly and safely.
>> Can you talk about how
Facebook is leveraging zero
trust, secure supply chains or
other modern cyber security
solutions?
>> Facebook focuses a lot of
engineering effort on secure
supply chains.
This extends to our use of the
Cloud as well, so our workloads
that will run externally have
all of the same requirements as
the internal ones in terms of
security, vulnerability
management, security logging,
monitoring, tight access control
to resources, access auditing,
data deletion requirements,
penetration testing, mandatory
reviews of anything with privacy
implications and so on.
One approach we're taking is
that our teams can't use any
UI's or directly control the
services they build in the
cloud.
They have to go through our tool
suite to do it.
Some of our suite uses
open-source -- a common open
source tools, which means there
are vast online help resources
available to enable our teams to
design and build their services.
Then, we provide our own
extensions so that these tools,
integrated with our existing
internal development work flows,
logging systems, dash boards, et
cetera.
It also allows us to impose our
own guardrails and best
practices.
It's infrastructure as code in
the truest sense.
Naturally, we already have an
internal CI/CD system that's
used to update our internal
services on a regular basis
after appropriate code reviews
and automated testing.
>> So I'd love to wrap up by
hearing about your experiences,
what your team uses to keep
Facebook fortified and
continually strengthen its
security posture, and two,
partnering.
>> One of the capabilities that
our tool chain allows is to
inspect what the deployment is
going to do before it happens,
which gives us an opportunity to
impose best practices or error
checking and stop problems from
going live.
Some of these rules shield us
from accidental security
exposure.
Some look for weak deployment
practices, such as a lack of
redundancy, and still others
look for avoidably expensive
practices.
These rules applied here are
based on both our own
experiences in policies, and
those recommended by our expert
partner teams supporting us.
This allows us to be agile and
respond to incidents when they
come to our attention.
>> Thanks, Murray and Steph.
Interesting to see how these
ideas are implemented, and I'm
excited to see where we'll
continue to go together.
Okay.
So let's move beyond our
infrastructure for a moment and
think about the big picture.
The software that runs your
business delivers value to your
customers and your users.
The security you're building is
designed to protect the users
and build trust between them and
you.
Security incidents erode that
trust, and eventually damage
your brand.
So now Google keeps more users
safe online than anyone else on
the world.
So let's see how we are
advancing our efforts and
delivering all these
capabilities to enterprises
wherever you are.
Eradicating phishing, as well as
completely stopping fraud.
Period.
And in this area, safe browsing
is the gold standard.
Our program to protect users
from dangerous sites or files is
unprecedented in its reach and
capability.
Its capabilities are invisibly
baked in to browsers on four
billion-plus devices.
Last year alone, we advanced the
state-of-the-art with enhanced
safe browsing, an optional but
more advanced level of security
for safe browsing the Web, and
by sharing real-time browsing
data in a privacy-preserving
way, we were able to deliver a
35 percent additional reduction
in phishing attacks and malware
that reach users.
These kinds of numbers and this
kind of efficacy has not been
possible without leaning in on
our heritage, and our core
competencies in providing
security as a built-in
capability to consumers, as well
as enterprises wherever they
are.
And since its introduction in
April 2020, in addition to safe
browsing, millions of users have
taken advantage of this extra
protection in a very rapid
fashion.
So our ultimate goal is to
eliminate phishing as a threat.
Period.
Bringing safe browsing
capabilities into your
environment through Gmail,
BeyondCorp Enterprise, and many
other products.
So in addition to targeting
users directly, attackers view
Web sites as the first and often
easiest place to commit fraud.
And over five million sites
today use Recapture, our fraud
andbot management solution that
stops attacks like potential
stopping and account takeovers.
With Recapture Enterprise, you
can do this frictionlessly
without user challenges to
maintain an optimal user
experience, which is just
another example of invisible
security.
And over and above this, we
continue to bring together the
best of Google's capabilities to
enhance fraud prevention.
So a new integration between
Cloud Armor and Recapture
Enterprise that detects and
stops bot activity at the edge
is now in preview.
So let's hear more from Brian
Lozada, the CSO at HBO Max on
how they're actually using
Recapture Enterprise to protect
their users, and therefore their
brand.
>> Thank you, Sunil.
We chose Recapture Enterprise
because we wanted to offer our
customers security against
malicious actors while
continuing to provide a
frictionless customer
experience.
With recapture enterprise, we
enable our customers through our
log-in and registration process
without requiring them to engage
in any kind of a challenge.
It's a win for everyone.
Our development and product
organizations can continue to
focus on creating customer
centric experiences and our
customers can easily use our
services.
The use of Recapture has helped
us in our mission to secure the
customer experience, allowing
our customers to feel
comfortable while enjoying our
platform.
Thank you.
>> Thank you, Brian.
So we want to provide as much
assistance as possible in your
digital transformation, or your
security transformation.
As Thomas mentioned in his
keynote, we are excited to
launch our new Google cyber
security action team to help.
And to talk more about this, I'd
love to kind of bring on Phil
Venables, our Cloud CSO, who's
leading this effort to tell you
more.
Phil.
>> Thanks, Sunil.
So the Google cyber security
action team marshals experts
from across Google to form what
we believe will be the world's
premier security advisory team.
It has a singular mission,
supporting the security and
digital transformation of
government, critical
infrastructure, enterprises,
small businesses, consumers and
society overall.
To deliver on this mission,
there are many ways the GCAT can
help you today, with strategic
advisory services for your
security strategy, including
transformational workshops and
content like our CSO guide to
security transformation, and our
framework for increasing
operational resilience for
financial services
organizations.
With trust and compliance
services driven by specialists
who continually obtain the most
important global compliance
certifications for our products,
and map them to industry control
frameworks for you.
We are full spectrum, customer
security and solutions
engineering that delivers proven
blueprints and architectures for
deploying our products and
services securely in accordance
with your regulatory regimes, as
well as comprehensive solutions
for areas like autonomic
security operations, cyber
resilience, zero trust
architectures, and many more
we've got under development.
And finally, with threat
intelligence and incident
response services, including
threat briefings, preparedness
drills and rapid response
engagements, so you can stay on
top of the evolving threat and
security landscape.
Another way we're working to
help strengthen and transform
security is by working with
industry and the public sector.
Google Cloud joined as an
initial partner for the U.S.
Department of Homeland
Security's Joint Cyber Defense
Collaborative, and this
initiative will strengthen our
collective security posture by
pre-empting and reducing the
impact of cyber threats through
increasingly strong partnerships
between the public and private
sectors, and as Sunil mentioned,
the White House Cybersecurity
Summit in August, we announced
that Google will invest $10
billion over the next five years
to further strengthen cyber
security.
The areas addressed included
expanding zero trust programs,
securing a software supply
chain, enhancing open-source
security, as well as training
100,000 Americans in skills,
including data privacy and
security through our Google
career certificate program.
And this builds on the $100
million we've already committed
to improving open source
security, focused on efforts
like Lenox kernel development,
work like metrics tracking, and
the coordinated vulnerability
disclosure through the Open
Source Security Foundation.
So with that, Sunil, back to you
to wrap up.
>> Thanks, Phil.
Great stuff.
As you can see, our commitment
to improving security for
customers in the whole ecosystem
is substantial.
And more importantly, it's
enduring.
In products, in resources, and
monetary returns.
We are making a meaningful
difference with our long-range
vision and commitment of
invisible security, delivering
continuously around zero trust,
safely securing your software
supply chain, and delivering
user protection services to
protect your users and your
brand.
So to close, I mentioned a few
new products, and I didn't have
time to cover all the other
amazing innovations that are
coming out of our teams.
And we are making many more such
announcements here at Next.
So please see our security
experts, fellow customers and
partners in our track sessions
to go deep on the topics and
product that matter most to you.
So don't forget, the live demo
of BeyondCorp Enterprise is
coming up next right here,
followed by a live Q&A, where we
will be answering your top
questions.
Thanks again, stay secure, and
have a great rest of Next.
>>Ly, everyone.
I'm macro.
>> And I'm tanesha.
>> In the security spotlight, we
heard about the importance of a
zero trust approach to security.
>> And in our demo today, we
will show you how to implement
zero trust access to be more
secure and more productive.
And a quick shoutout to our
audience.
This is truly live.
Dive into the chat.
We want to hear from you.
Tell us what you do and where
you're joining from.
We can see you.
Check it out, macro.
>> Sure enough, we can see
everybody down here, and we're
so excited to interact and talk
to you all today.
If you're still hanging out in
the next event Web site, click
on the blue button that says
join the interactive experience
to activate these features.
So let's get into it.
We're going to cover three
things.
One, how your entire workforce
can securely access legacy and
modern applications without
exposing your network to
attacks.
And two, how you can get better
protection against threats and
data loss right from within your
Brow
browser.
And three, how you can gain
visibility in the unsafe
activity even if users aren't on
a corporate network or device
and we're going to do all this
with beyBeyondCorp enterprise.
This is Google Cloud's zero
access trust solution.
With BCE, you can use Chrome to
access apps and resources.
In the background, Google's
network protects and proxies
traffic, enforcing access
policies.
These policies use factories
such as identity, device info,
location and third party signals
to authorize access to apps and
data that you need to do your
job.
>> That's awesome, Marco.
So let's get to the good stuff.
Think about it.
How easy is it for your
developers to work remotely and
securely right now?
We know it's a tough task.
We know that making life easy
for developers will also
protecting your code is
critical.
That's why our new BeyondCorp
Enterprise feature client
connector is so important.
It enables zero tech access to
legacy thick line applications.
>> Yeah.
I think a lot of people run into
that today.
So let's take a look at how
developers would use this.
We set up this laptop for the
Cymbal group.
>> By the way, they're a
fictional company.
Cymbal has been around since the
1970s, and they haven't
modernized all their
applications.
Sound familiar?
One of their main developer
applications is still hosted in
a private data center.
>> Yeah, I see this quite a bit.
Until recently, Cymbal
developers didn't have a way to
access this application remotely
without a VPN.
The security team had constant
concerns that remote users could
expose the network or even
worse, their source code to
attacks or hackers.
But now, using BeyondCorp
Enterprise client connector,
they can access client server
ae
apps without a VPN.
Let me show you how users would
connect via SSH to their server
com pos Torre, and let me just
say, don't blink or you might
miss it.
It's that simple.
So let's go ahead and swing on
over to our developer machine.
From here, I can simply open up
Google Chrome.
Once Google Chrome has actually
loaded, you can see I've
authenticated to my application
repository already.
I simply click on the end point
verification extension and from
here I click on start
connection.
My end point is being postured
in the background and secure
connection is being made to Get
Lab.
From there, I can simply, then,
once it's turned green, of
course, minimize my browser, and
then on the left-hand side, I'm
going to go ahead and open up my
terminal application.
This is my thick client
application.
I'm going to then go ahead and
run a Git clone, and that's
actually going to pull down the
code from Git to my local
machine.
And there's my application
pulled down locally on to my end
point.
I know that probably seemed
pretty straightforward, but what
you might not have noticed was
first, there were no clients.
It's all in the browser you
probably already had open.
Second, in the background,
continuously validating the
identity and the device and a
bunch of other factors is our
identity ware proxy.
And third, our TCP proxy
seamlessly and securely forwards
all the traffic.
The fact that developers around
the world with do this remotely,
simply, and securely without all
the hassle of a VPN is pretty
awesome.
>> And, with BeyondCorp
Enterprise, workers are only
allowed access to applications
they're permitted to use.
So we prevent unwanted lateral
movement across the network.
So, audience, we want to know,
would you use this method for
remote access in your
organization?
>> Awesome.
Now, let's see how your
workforce can securely access
modern Web applications even
from noncorporate devices.
Let's look at how Cymbal does it
for their extended workforce,
their call center contractors.
>> Meet Rhonda.
She's one of thousands remote
contractors who help with
Cymbal's 24/7 support during the
holiday shopping season.
So security community, can you
share in our chat, in the past
year, have you onboarded new
temporary workers?
Did you send them a laptop or
make them install software so
they could be more secure?
>> Looks like that would be a
yes.
Contractors also tend to be more
vulnerable to attacks.
Last year, 44 percent of
organizations experienced a
breach, and 74 percent of those
breaches were the result of
giving too much privilege access
to third parties.
So for Cymbal, keeping those
users off the corporate network
decreases the risk of being
exposed to attacks like ran
ransomware, and here's where
using BeyondCorp Enterprise
comes in again for Cymbal.
Contractors and other employees
were able to BYOD, onboard
quickly and use a device that
they feel comfortable with while
BCE layers of protection keep
them secure.
>> That way, Rhonda can have
secure access from her own
device with clear separation
between work and personal
activity.
Let me show you exactly what she
sees as she begins her day.
She first navigates to her
Google Chrome browser.
Then she navigates to her Cymbal
call center application.
We'll enter in our credentials.
We'll then do two-factor
authentication with our timed
security key.
Now that we've passed two-factor
authentication, we are in our
Cymbal call center application.
You saw Rhonda log in to Chrome
with her Cymbal credentials.
This is what we call a
BeyondCorp protector profile.
It extends threat and data
protection as soon as she logs
in.
As you can see, our agentless
approach means no additional
software.
She gets right to work on her
own device rather than picking
up a laptop from IT and waiting
hours while everything gets
configured, therefore saving
time and money.
>> Awesome to note.
And the thing about zero trust
access is that we don't
automatically trust Rhonda just
because she has log-in
credentials.
Authorization is continuous, not
just when she first logs in.
BeyondCorp Enterprise enforces
Cymbal's contractor access
policies based on her identity,
and contextual information about
her device and location, as well
as the fact that she's
authenticated with her tighten
key.
So security community, we want
to know, what do you all use for
multi-factor authentication?
SMS code, security keys?
Maybe an authentication app?
Or maybe something else
completely.
Hopefully it's not nothing.
>> For me, it's my security key.
Every day.
Especially since I don't always
have my phone on me.
>> Yep.
Same here.
They're so easy to use, and they
provide the strongest protection
against phishing.
Regardless of what you use, some
form of multi-factor
authentication is critical for
basic security hygiene, and we
highly recommend it, especially
for remote access.
So let's take a look.
I don't know if anybody has
anything.
Looks like most people use,
let's say, security keys.
B?
Awesome.
That's what we love to hear.
So let's get back to Rhonda, who
just authenticated to the app,
and explore how we can integrate
threat and data protection right
from within a browser.
>> Great.
Let's see her get to work and
see how BCE protects Cymbal,
their customers and Rhonda with
ease.
It's been a really busy day.
She doesn't have enough time to
finish processing a batch of
customer refunds before her next
call.
She wants to save the customer
credit card information to a
local file and do the refunds
when things slow down, but
saving this sensitive
information to another location
is against Cymbal's security
policy.
Let me show you her experience.
Let's navigate to our credit
card file, and let's download
this so Rhonda can do the
refunds at another time.
As you can see, she's blocked.
You can see a message appear at
the bottom that prevents her
from doing so.
>> Yeah.
Exactly.
You can actually see where the
credit card PDF has sensitive
dangerous content inside of it.
And I'll show you a policy
that's been configured for
Cymbal that will detect risky
behaviors just like these.
So let's go ahead and look at
her administrative console here,
admin.Google.com.
Over on the left-hand side, you
can see the security menu, and
if you scroll down underneath
security, you can actually see
data protection.
And we're going to go ahead and
authenticate, obviously, as
administrators securely, so
let's go ahead and type in our
password.
And once I've authenticated,
I'll be able to go ahead and
look at my data protection
policies.
You'll notice here where it says
managed rules, so we're going to
go ahead and go on the managed
rules, and we can actually see
the credit card detection
policy.
I've also got detectors for
things like Social Security or
even detecting code that's been
copied or pasted or shared by
the developers.
So as the admin, you can decide
if you want to automatically
block user actions, as Cymbal
has done here, or if you want to
trigger a warning to the user
instead.
>> And in addition to things
like credit card numbers, you
can also set specific DLP
policies to detect file type as
source code.
So that way you can protect
sensitive information and code
by monitoring, controlling or
even blocking what people upload
or download.
>> Yeah.
Exactly.
We can use very granular
policies for this type of
information in order to protect
against exfiltration.
So we just showed you some of
the types of data protection
policies you can set up.
You can also customize access
policies and the changes take
effect in real-time.
This is a really big deal,
because you get continuous
checking of whether a user is in
a policy giving you up to the
second security controls.
In fact, let's make an update
here in real-time for Rhonda.
So, okay, community, we're going
to ask you which policy we
should change.
Is it her location?
Maybe her operating system
policy, or whether or not she's
on a corporate-owned device.
Please chime in here.
We'd really love to understand
and hear what you guys deem
impor
important.
While we wait for the results to
come in, I will say that I see
these kinds of things all the
time with my customers.
They want to be able to
dynamically change policies
depending on their
circumstances.
In particular, some customers
are really interested in
controlling for location,
perhaps limiting access to only
certain countries.
Additionally, if a company is
going through an org change or
maybe a merger, being able to
change access policies for
select groups of users or
departments in real-time is
crucial, and beyond these three
choices in the poll, there are
many other ways to customize
your access policies based on
what your organization needs.
So let's go ahead and look back
at the polls.
And looks like corporate on
device.
So awesome.
I love it.
And thanks for everybody
contributing.
Let's go ahead and do this right
now.
So we're going to go ahead and
jump on over into our GCP cloud
console, and from here we can
see our identity ware proxy.
We can actually see our Cymbal
Git lab for developer
application.
We can also see our call center
And again, these applications
can be anywhere, and for this
demo, they're in GCP.
We're going to go ahead and
select the call center
application and down at the
bottom, we can see Rhonda over
on the right-hand side and her
application access policy.
Let's go ahead and edit that,
and we're going to go ahead and
remove the existing access
policy that's allowing access
from Europe and the U.S., and
we're going to go ahead and
delete that one, and we're going
to add a new role.
We're simply going to go ahead
and select cloud IEP, IEP Web
app user and from there we're
going to go ahead and select
access policy, which everybody
chose, and that was require
corporate device, right?
Okay.
I just wanted to make sure I
remembered that correctly.
Let's go ahead and save that in
place.
Click save.
And when we save that policy,
it's actually going to be
propagated across the world
within a very short period of
time.
All of the proxies across
Google's global network are
immediately updated.
So the next time any user tries
to access a protective resource,
they're evaluated against that
new policy set.
We mentioned continuous
authorization earlier, and this
is a key part of that.
Authorization is not a one-time
occurrence.
So even if you begin a new
session that doesn't mean you'll
have perpetual access.
>> Exactly.
And for companies like Cymbal
that employ hourly and temp
workers, the ability to
dynamically update access
conditions is important.
For instance, they could set
these policies so workers only
access applications and
resources during their shift
hours, or working days, or only
allow access from -- only allow
access from specific
geographies.
They also may want to require
that devices have the most
up-to-date operating systems,
and security patches.
So this is an important
condition to manage, especially
for all the contractors using
their own devices.
>> Yep.
Exactly.
So because Rhonda doesn't need
th
meet that condition which I just
updated, she will no longer be
able to access the call center
application.
Now, I think we've all faced
this, and it's one of the most
frustrating things about remote
access, especially when you're
using the VPN.
You think you should have access
to something, but for some
reason, it's just not working.
>> It's the worst!
So let's see if our real-time
change worked.
So when Rhonda tries to open a
new task in the call center
application, let's take a look
at what she sees.
Let's navigate back to our home.
And she's denied access as a
result of the change Marco just
did.
But once again, BCE has Rhonda
covered.
She can report this error using
our new feature, the BeyondCorp
Enterprise policy troubl
troubleshooter, which informs
end users that they're blocked
and tells them how to get help
quickly.
So as you can see here, she will
follow the prompt to E-mail to
admin to get help.
Let's go ahead and E-mail our
admin.
Our admin is now notified of us
being blocked.
With BeyondCorp Enterprise
policy troubleshooter, admins
can quickly fix issues that are
blocking users, keeping them
productive.
>> Yep.
You bet.
Let me show you what the Cymbal
admin would see on the other
side of this request, and how
they can unblock users like
Rhonda.
So we're going to go ahead and
switch gears.
Let's go over to G mail, another
Google application, and it looks
like we got a notification for
credit card detection, which is
good.
So we know if Rhonda is taking
some interesting actions within
her end point.
Oh, and it looks like we just
got an E-mail from Rhonda
because she's actually been
blocked to an application.
There's the link that she sent
over, so let's go ahead and
click on that and we'll
automatically be logged directly
into the Google Cloud platform.
So from here, I can actually see
the different policies and
bindings that are in place, so
let's go ahead and select the
call center application and over
on the right-hand side here, we
can actually see the granted
conditions, or the denials
themselves.
So let's go ahead and look at
the binding details.
So interestingly, here we can
see that Rhonda failed to meet
any of the access levels and
sure enough, it's requiring a
corporate device, which was not
granted.
So I'd normally go back and
block her by updating that
policy, so her access levels are
evaluated like any other
contractor, but we're going to
keep moving, just in the
interest of time.
>> Sounds good.
That was so easy, by the way.
>> Yeah.
Super easy.
Now, let's look how BCE can give
us better visibility into unsafe
user activities, whether they're
unsuccessful access attempts
like we just saw, or other
activities across the apps that
BCE protects.
Let me pull up the security
dashboards in Chrome and give
you all a look.
So we're going to jump back over
into our Google admin console
here and in the same security
menu on the left-hand side, we
can actually click on
dashboards.
Wait for those to load out for a
second.
So something to make note of
here is that with Chrome data
protection, you're actually
going to get a whole slew of
different information.
We can see Chrome high-risk
users, we can see individual DSP
incidents, if we wanted to
scroll down a little bit, we
could actually see how many
users are forgetting their pass
words, if I can figure out how
to use the track pad here.
So we can see user log-in
attempts, we can see, for
example, messages that are
encrypted, but what we're
interested in is whether or not
those credit card numbers are
making it through.
So let's go ahead and drill in a
little bit in to one of these
reports.
So we can see every single file
uploaded, file downloaded, Web
content upload, for example, and
we can actually see every single
time that this took place for
our Social Security detection,
as well as credit card
detection, and if we were
actually to drill in on credit
card detection here, I think
this is really cool, so I just
want to show everybody real
quick here, since we do have
like another minute, and that is
all the sensitive data transfers
that are taking place, blocked,
detected or otherwise.
So even if your organization
isn't using all corporate-owned
devices, you can still monitor
security events and investigate
those alerts.
>> That's awesome, Marco.
Audience, so what do you think?
Let us know in the chat.
We definitely know this is
something of interest.
In the last 15 minutes, you've
seen how entire workforce can
access modern and legacy
applications securely, how you
can improve threat and data
protection, and how you can get
better visibility in to risky
activity even on unmanaged
devices.
>> Yeah.
Our call goal, right, at the end
of the day, with BeyondCorp
Enterprise is to make your
experience more productive and
more secure, and our team looks
forward to supporting you on
your zero trust journey.
>> Thanks so much for joining us
today and participating.
We have a live Q&A coming up
next to answer all of your
Google Cloud security questions.
As well as any questions you
might have had from the demo.
So please stick around.
>> Yeah.
Please do.
And thank you all for joining.
We'll see you all soon.
>> Bye!
>> Awesome.
Thanks so much Tanesha and
Marco.
That was an incredible demo.
It's always fun to see our
products in action and I'm sure
between the great spotlight
earlier, the demo, our audience
has some great questions lined
up.
So thank you for joining
everyone today.
My name is Iman.
>> And I'm Sri.
I'm so thrilled to be here
answering your questions live
from our fabulous studio here in
Sunnyvale.
>> Awesome.
We're also joined by the team
that just took you through that
live demo just a few minutes
ago, so you may see them pop up
to help answer questions
throughout the shoI  show.
Okay.
Let's jump right in with a
little poll.
Tell us what got you most
excited today.
Is it our trusted cloud?
Is it our zero trust philosophy?
Is it our $10 billion
cybersecurity investment or is
it the cybersecurity action
team?
And by the way, I'm waiting for
these poll results, so while we
wait for these results, just a
reminder, this Q&A is live, so
you can engage with us directly.
So Steve, Brian, Danesh, I'm
watching all of you right here
live on the chat.
So if you can't, just go back to
the next event Web site and
click on the blue join the
interactive experience button.
And as we give you some time to
submit your poll, I want to hear
the scoop from you, Sri, so tell
us what you're most excited
about.
>> I am really excited about the
zero trust model.
I feel like we're kind of
adopting it, and we're seeing a
lot of people move toward it.
So --
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, we've been doing this
for so long, right?
You know, we're taking an
approach that we've pine neared
and we're putting it out in the
world and we're watching a lot
of customers sort of adopting
this approach now.
>> Yes.
Absolutely.
>> Awesome.
Awesome.
>> Oh, looks like it is.
>> It looks like it is, yeah.
That's right.
Looks like a lot of people are
really excited about zero trust.
That's amazing.
Okay.
Cool.
What's the next?
We've got our $10 billion
cybersecurity investment, but
zero trust is definitely leading
by a pretty big margin.
All right.
So let's go ahead and get
started.
Let's kick off our first
question.
Yeah?
>> All right.
Sounds good.
Cool.
So I guess while we're waiting
for questions from the audience
to populate, the question I have
for you is why is security
dominating the headlines?
>> You have to be under a rock
to not, like, you know, notice
all the stuff that's happening
around us, all the IPO's, with
Forge Rock and Dark Trace and
we're seeing presidents and
prime ministers commit a large
amount, a giant amount of
dollars, including our new
president, to security.
And so I think there are two
things here.
Typically, in industry, we'll
see a lot of movement because
there is a technology shift that
happens, and we're seeing that,
too, with the digital
transformation, you know, the
way that we secure our
environments has changed, and so
there's a lot of movement that's
happening in this industry
because of that.
Added to that security has this
other thing, where it's also
driven by the people who are
attacking the, you know, the
attacks that are happening, and
we're seeing a huge amount of
attacks happening today.
And as a result, like, for
example, we've had -- I mean,
this is really sad.
We've had our first death that
happened because of a ransomware
this year.
We've had a pipeline company
have to pay a ton of money for a
ransomware.
We have had manufacturing
companies get disrupted in their
manufacturing company, basically
had a disruption pretty
recently.
And so we're seeing a lot of
this happen all around us.
And that's kind of adding more,
you know, focus into this area,
where people are starting to
realize that this is an
important area that needs a lot
of investment because otherwise
businesses are going to suffer
because of nations are going to
suffer, and that's I think part
of the reason that we're seeing
this doubling of that
exponential growth.
>> You mentioned a couple great
things.
Like, I noticed that the cloud
evolution has allowed a lot of
businesses to sort of transform
the way they work, the way they
offer services and products to
their consumers, and we as human
beings are now more dependent on
technology now more than ever,
and so I always like to say
that, like, you know, cyber
security is going to start to be
seen as a service-oriented role,
an honorable role in society
because we have customers who
build healthcare systems on our
cloud, industrial systems on our
cloud, you know, offer all sorts
of services, right?
And as we become more and more
dependent on technology, we need
to ensure that we're also
advancing the state of how
secure our infrastructure is so
that we can protect our
customers and protect people at
the end of the day.
So looks like we got a question
from Jeanette, which is what
makes Google's cloud more secure
and trusted than its
competitors?
>> So Google actually started
building a lot of these security
products for itself, right?
So Google is known as a very
secure company, and so what
we've done recently is taken
some of the work that we have
done to secure our own
corporations or our own
customers, like, you know,
BeyondCorp that we just saw the
demo for, or recapture, and
productized it, and the vision
here is that every customer can
be just as secure as Google is.
But add to that this idea of
innovation that's there at
Google.
So, for example, when we decided
to go in to the federal space
and do a fed drop certification,
instead of just standing up a
couple of data centers near
North Virginia and saying, like,
let's do that, let's -- you
know, this is a set of
customers, let's give them a
cloud that is compliant to their
needs, we decided to make all of
Google Cloud the -- so now a
customer in Brazil can leverage
those features just as much as
if every customer might.
And so I think there's this
leaning in to the forefront of
security that we're now seeing
with the trusted partner cloud.
For example, we had a couple of
announcements last week.
We had an announcement, and
we're sort of saying that you
ca
can, a lot of nations want to be
able to own their own
infrastructure and their own
destiny.
And so we're taking the Google
Cloud and kind of making it
available to them in a way that
they own it and they operate it,
and so that's another thing that
we're doing that's kind of
pushing the boundaries.
And I think this is just this
idea of pushing the boundary
that is what makes Google really
special.
>> Yeah.
I think you mentioned something
that's really important, which
is like because we own all of
our infrastructure and we've
served billions of users all
around the world through G mail,
through Search and through all
this, it's kind of a no-brainer
that we also allow enterprises
and small businesses to also now
revamp the way that they do
their operations on our cloud
and on our infrastructure, and
so we are able to do global
changes like that with the fed
ramp certification, where we do
manage all of our infrastructure
end-to-end, which is a big, big
owning of this.
It allows us to govern our cloud
more securely, more efficiently,
and also to pioneer really
significant changes for our
cloud and all of our customers
worldwide.
>> Hundred percent.
>> Yeah.
All right.
We got the next question, which
is from Azumi.
The question is, which operating
systems does BCE support?
Does BCE support third-party
clouds or on-premise
application?
And I believe this question
would be probably best suited
for Marco.
>> Yeah, I can answer that
question.
So the beauty of BeyondCorp, and
I would just say based on
obviously the breadth and width
of our Chrome browser is that we
can support any operating system
at this point, so whether it's
Chrome LS, obviously, which we
love and hold near and dear to
our hearts, or windows or Mac OS
or Linux or android or iOS, we
support all of them.
So your users aren't going to be
limited to a particular
operating system, which is
great, especially when you are
an organization trying to
enable, right, enable your
employees and your contractors.
On top of that, we support
everything from thick client
applications, right, to
server-based applications,
Web-based applications.
It could be, you know, HTTP,
TCP-based protocols.
There's no limit at this point
in time.
So kind of imagination is the
limit.
>> Yeah.
I mean, as someone who probably
doesn't get as much exposure to
BeyondCorp and getting hands on
as I used to, I really loved
your demo, and so that was
really super helpful, and I
can't wait to go back and
rewatch it.
We've got another question from
Tara, which is in the spotlight,
Sunil spoke a lot about
invisible security.
So two questions.
This is two-pronged.
If security is invisible, does
that mean that I can't change
the settings or decide what
security I want?
And two, does invisible security
mean that security is free?
>> It's a great question.
I think I would like to step
back and see where the problem
is, right?
So the problem we're trying to
solve is that there is an alert
fatigue that we're trying to
deal with, right?
There's, you know, most
corporations can't even look at,
forget about processing, about
50 percent of the alerts that
they get.
So you're starting to see all
these alerts coming in.
You don't look at it.
And there's a lot of work being
done to bubble up the more
important alerts, and put them
in front of the sock and so
forth, but that still means that
there are 50 percent of the
alerts that you don't even look
at, right?
So the idea is, are there things
that we can do to prevent
certain type of action, for
example, that might not be
kosher action without creating
friction in the business.
So based on the business' own
rules, or policies that you can
write, are there policies that
you can write, what can you
build into the platform?
Anyway, bringing down the number
of alerts and number of things
that you want to watch, and how
do you actually guide things to
happen.
And so this idea of moving from
just all this risk bonding to
things, to maybe preventing
things, maybe guiding people in
the right direction.
A great example is there was a
customer who once told me that
just by sometimes popping up a
question, like, you know, is
this something that you want to
do?
You'll find that a large number
of people will just not do it,
right?
And so you can -- there are a
lot of different ways that you
can prevent certain things from
happening, and that, I think, is
the core to what invisible
security is about.
So it is based on things that
someone might configure, and
it's based on the business logic
that that company wants to have,
and it's not something that just
invisible in the sense that you
lose visibility into your
security.
It's invisible in that, you
know, there are things that you
don't need to do and they're not
coming at you all the time.
>> Automate as much as possible.
It's like no security person
ever said that their job is
completely stress-free.
And it's easy, right?
And so, you know, I always like
to say that, you know, we as
humans, we do security in our
everyday lives.
When we leave the house, we put
our seat belts on, we lock the
doors.
We've been taught over all these
years of evolution, how to be
secure, right?
Some of us more than others,
right?
And then when we get into our
digital lives on the cloud, we
have to relearn all these
things.
And some of them we have to
build into our infrastructure so
that they become part of our
background processes, and some
of it comes through user
enablement and some of it comes
through the amazing products
that we serve.
Security is the core of how we
advance all of the amazing
things that we're doing at
humans in to this new world
where everything is
technology-driven and whatnot.
We got a question.
And this one is for Tanesha,
probably.
I would say, Tanesha, what
applications does BCE support?
>> Thanks.
BCE supports all applications
from IS to SAS to thick client
applications as well.
And like Marco mentioned, we
support HTTP and HTTPS, in ad to
TCP protocols like SSH and RDP.
>> Awesome.
And I see a lot of great chatter
from the audience, Robby, Joey,
thank you for engaging.
All right.
Cool.
So we got another question from
jean Mikael, sorry if I
pronounced your name wrong.
Can you only use the Chrome
browser for BCE?
And then how do you make sure
the Chrome browser is in use is
the approved one, the Chrome
browser that's in use is the
approved one, not another Chrome
instance, that could be a man in
the middle.
>> Yeah, that totally makes
sense.
So this is kind of the beauty of
context policies.
We can force these policies down
to the browser level, versions,
for example, what kind of
browsers able to access.
If it's a corporate managed
browser or device, you can wrap
policies around all of that, so
you can get very, very granular.
And I would say the other side
of this is we want users to be
able to use what browser they
want, right, for personal
access.
I think that's great.
And we should continue to
support that if that's what they
want and if that's what the
corporation wants.
But as far as accessing
corporate resources, it's just
like anything else, right?
You want to be able to manage it
and we're not going to
necessarily just trust anything.
So having a trusted Chrome
browser for accessing corporate
applications works great for our
customers, and it's just the
best method to kind of move
forward.
So hopefully that answers your
question.
>> Thanks, Marco.
Yeah.
All right.
We got a question from Robert,
and this is how is Google's zZeo
Trust Model different than other
competing hyper-scalers?
>> So I think zero trust model
is -- so Google's Zero Trust
Model, and I think there's a
world that's adopting the Zero
Trust Model.
There's only one model.
There isn't a Zero Trust Model
and someone else's trust model.
And the Zero Trust Model is very
similar to maybe I think an
analogy is the things that
happen today as we got into the
studio.
We -- you know, we've all been,
you know, vaccinated and tested
multiple times in the last week.
And still when we came in, we
got tested again, and then we
were masked and had a shield,
and we were doing that up until
we were in front of the camera,
and as soon as this is all done,
we're going to be masked and,
you know, sent out, right?
So this idea that you have
access to something just at the
time that you have access, and
there's context to whether you
need access or not, and where
you're coming from and what
you're doing and that should all
be added in to the decision
making of what you are, I think
that's what is zero trust.
And it's great that it was
pioneered by Google, but today
that is a model that is being
used everywhere.
I think where the question may
be coming from is about the
BeyondCorp Enterprise and how is
that differentiated.
And I think the key thing here
is we've seen the track record
of Google in terms of keeping
our employees and our data safe
through BeyondCorp Enterprise,
and we're trying to get that out
to our customers, and the one
thing that I would like to point
out is the Zero Trust Model
isn't just one tool.
It's a mindset.
It's a way in which we do
things.
And I'm really excited about
GCAT, the announcement that we
just made about the
cybersecurity action team, where
we're going to be having like
these security experts and
CSO's, people like Phil Venable
available to our customers to
think through this model and
think through end-to-end how
they're actually going to be
implementing it, and so that's
the exciting thing, I think,
overall.
We have the pioneering product.
We have the knowledge of zeZero
Trust end-to-end.
We've actually implemented it
and we've proven it.
>> I love the analogy you've put
together about COVID and
whatnot, because it's like we
went from traditional network
centric boundaries to identity
centric boundaries, and now it's
like who are you and what's your
purpose and what are all the
other factors in to why you
should be performing this
action.
And I think one of the most
amazing things about when I
first joined Google was not
having to use a VPN, and just
work, and I thought that was
really nice.
So we're going to go to a
question from Amitab from Ford.
So the question is how do we
implement zero trust in our org?
>> This is a great question.
And I'm going to actually throw
that question to you.
You're in the solutions team.
So let's talk about this, right?
You know, how do we implement
Zero Trust in the org, and I
guess it starts with BeyondCorp,
but what are all the factors
that you think about?
>> I always like to say that a
lot of big workload
transformations in security are
not just a matter of buying a
product and paying for a
service.
It takes a lot of enablement and
education from the top down and
from the bottom up.
We have to structurally think
about how we're going to
transform the way that we work,
and what implications those have
on the way that we work today
and what our pros and cons are
and where our approach is going
to be and what our strategy is
going to be to sort of get
there, and that strategy is
going to be augmented by people,
by teams, by development teams,
by tools, by partners, so when
we advise customers and we sit
down with clients and we talk
about solutions, right, and
helping transform elements of
their business, we don't just
talk about how a product can be
leveraged in your organization.
Because we've got product teams
that can talk about the product.
We talk about how we can
actually transform the business,
how we can get the whole
organization to culturally
transform the way that they work
and how we can get on a tangible
path to achieving a zero trust
architecture in their workforce,
and that may be a multi-year
strategy, right?
And so there's many, many, many
different layers to this.
>> I agree.
I think there's this whole thing
about you can think of a
question only in -- you know,
you can think of a product, and
a particular problem that you're
trying to solve, but if you're
not thinking about it
end-to-end, like security is
just as strong as the weakest
link, right?
And so if you have a contractor
who has direct access, then you
have a problem there.
>> Yeah.
>> So you're thinking about the
thing end-to-end.
>> Awesome.
Awesome.
And by the way, big shout-out to
the GCAP for bringing on that
security advisory role.
So we've got one last question
here, and I'm going to give you
this last question, which is
what do you mean by shared fate
and how is that different from
shared responsibility?
>> That's a great question.
So shared responsibility has
really unfortunately come to
mean divvying up
responsibilities.
I'm responsible for something
and you're responsible for
something else.
And so that is not the
partnership approach that Google
wants.
What we want is to be able to
say, well, we're sharing the
responsibility, and we're
sharing the fate from that
responsibility.
So we're doing two things.
One is we're making sure that
we're bringing in all the data,
like, to you in terms of
configurations that you might
have in terms of secure landing
zone or secure blueprints, and
then we also have risk manager
to quantify and then be able to
address your risk.
So all of that is what shared
fate is, where we're actually
being part of the process with
the customer.
>> Awesome.
Thank you all for joining us
today.
And big thanks to Sri, Tanesha,
and Marco for sharing their
insights.
That's all we have for you on
the live show today.
Be sure to check out our great
on demand content.
Our live program kicks off
tomorrow at 9A.M. Pacific with
our community spotlight.
Thanks for joining us.
.